hello everybody hello hello do i sound better now i guys do
i sound better now i don't know i i i dug through i dug
through the the the grave of our of old pc koon and managed
to find the old sound settings so i need to know if i'm
better now Everything sounds better.
Oh my god.
Yes, but a bit loud.
Okay, let me adjust that real quick.
How do I do that?
Uh.
Oh, wait.
I can turn this down to, uh, there.
Is that better?
Is that better, everybody?
Am I still loud?
I mean, I'm always loud.
Like, you telling me, like, Doki, you're just a bit too
loud.
that's just saying Doki stop breathing air like I don't know
a sound guy here guys I'm just a mess okay you aren't loud
okay good okay sound guy says I'm not loud so I'll put it
back to 100% all right nice do I sound the same sound guy do
I sound like I you I sound like on PC Koon may he rest in
peace I now have a hotter younger uh version of you but like
I still miss you like I'm not gonna forget the memories
you've given me
Oh my god It's been, it's a wild It's been wild There's so
many announcements So if you guys didn't know If you guys
didn't follow I need to like There's so many announcements I
need to make on I need to make on the community post on
YouTube Because it's building up There's a lot of
conventions A lot of world tour stuff for conventions um a
lot of uh a lot of like announcements a lot of merch coming
out so you guys didn't follow me on twitter uh today hi and
ipp have announced uh uh that i will be at anime expo
remember during the charity event thing uh where i was like
hey guys i'm gonna be um i'm gonna be i'm gonna be at the
anime expo this is what it is i'll be at anime expo Expo.
At first it was originally like, you know, I'd just be there
for July 4th to 6th because that's when Anime Expo is going
to be.
And then they realize, wait, it's your birthday on July 4th.
Yes, my real birthday.
For those who don't know, July 4th is my actual real
birthday.
Because you're like, wait a minute, Doki, didn't you
celebrate your birthday like a couple of months?
No, this is my real birthday
so so on July 4th I will be celebrating my one of my five
real birthdays and IVP and Hyatt found out they're like wait
July 4th is your real birthday I was like yeah yeah and then
they're like why don't we like make the booth like Decorate
it to birthday theme for you, which was really sweet.
They didn't have to like I was just going to be there as a
guest and stuff So like it was really sweet of them to offer
to do like a birthday theme for my booth just for like the
sake of it just being my birthday Because they're they're
just going to decorate it like dokey theme But because they
found out it was also my birthday They're like we're going
to make it more like celebratory to celebrate your birthday
and everything So it was really sweet.
So there's going to be some announcements at the um ibp
slash hi at booth but don't worry like some of these
announcements will of course be posted uh on social media
regarding what it is because we're gonna be announcing it at
the booth and then like whatever the announcements are we're
gonna be posting it on um social media i'll also be
streaming on my birthday so so uh so you don't have to worry
about that i'll also be streaming
After the, I believe it'll be a panel on the fourth.
So after the panel, there will be a birthday stream as well
for all the dragoons who won't be there.
Because it's going to be treated like, you know, like anime
conventions, like panels and stuff like that.
So whatever I'm doing there, it's just like the usual, like
what I usually do for conventions.
So like a panel, a karaoke, and a meet and greet.
So the only bonus is that during the panel, there'll be
celebrating my birthday.
I'll still have my regular birthday stream.
It's not like, oh, like Anime Expo is the birthday stream.
There will be a birthday stream after the Anime Expo panel
that's hosted by, that's hosted by IBP slash Hyatt.
So look forward to that.
What else?
U2s.
My U2s figure is out now.
We've almost hit a thousand sales already, which is great
news.
I thank you so much for supporting my very first figure.
I hope there will be many more to come.
I hope, like, the success of this YouTube's figure might
reflect on more potential collapse in the future.
So please feel free to check out the YouTube's figure, and I
believe my mod will post a link to it very soon.
It was really funny because, like, okay, it's a little
embarrassing because apparently Hyatt and YouTube's was
watching the stream.
They were both watching the stream because, you know, after
the whole mess earlier, we're guiding, you know, the four
Windows 11 keys.
So, like, you know, I finally activated Windows, by the way,
because they, Hayek gave me, like, extra instructions on how
to, like, being like, oh, go to Command and type these
random magical letters and stuff.
and then so then i did that and it worked so then so then
they replied now you have three extra keys
this is what one of the high employees or like ibp employees
wrote to me
so it was supposed to be a secret so now i have three window
and 11 keys um one of them which i paid 200 for because i
was panicking and freaking out because i was like i have a
stream but i can't activate my windows what if i just buy a
windows key myself maybe that's the problem maybe that's the
issue i need to purchase my own windows key and then yeah
it's okay it was 200 kinney okay it's not it's not as okay
but like it was two at least it was 200 canadian and not 200
american anyway also youtube was also watching the stream
because they were like uh oh yeah they were like oh yeah did
you like average like did you like uh give a shout out to
the youtube figure um they're like oh i don't know if you
did a shout out to the youtube figure because it launched
yesterday um what do you uh it's okay if you talk about it
on like you know today's stream and then later on they're
like never mind Sponsored your funerals.
They're like, oh, never mind.
We saw that you two sponsored the funerals, so you're good
to go.
So, so, so yay.
My sponsors watch my stream.
So they found out that they like, you know, they
accidentally sponsored my PC Kun's funeral book.
This is what the YouTube's person said.
I thought it was so funny.
This is what you wanted, YouTube's.
You got the best prime spot.
It's like the Super Bowl.
It's like the Super Bowl, chat.
You know, but like cheaper.
Anyone would want to sponsor a funeral, as high prolific as
PC coon chat.
Albert, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fonda, thank you for the super chat.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
At the funny doki figuring from YouTube so description for
increased marketing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, it's so, it's like, it's such a rare opportunity.
How many funerals are you able to legally sponsor chat?
Just think about it, guys.
It's like prime real estate.
It's, I honestly think it's like the next marketing genius
move because it's like, they're dead anyway.
And funerals are so expensive, but all the family loved ones
will be there because they're like, oh, he's dead.
I, you know, I got to pay my respect.
So it's like, and it's like different demographics too.
People from like different ages and demographics will be
there.
So, like, funeral caskets are not cheap.
And you gotta buy land for the grave, too.
So, like, imagine, like, you know, you can grab a sponsor.
And then, you know, sponsored by Coca-Cola.
And then Coca-Cola gets a gray spot that's gonna be there
for centuries.
Just think about that.
Like, you know, the gravestone with a Coca-Cola emblem on
there.
and the sponsored casket you can paint the casket red and
like you know put the coca-cola logo on the top when you
like you know when you know after you close the lid on the
on the you know when you pay your respect the lids open and
then you close the lid there's the coca-cola like logo there
and everything and then the casket can have be painted red
um and you don't have to pay anything because they'll be
sponsored by coca-cola you know they're dead already like
and you serve coca-cola at the funeral like the you know
like the those funeral part okay i wouldn't i can't say
parties but it's not really it's not really a party but like
you know like the funeral get together with everybody
getting like i'm going to hell
I'm definitely going to hell with this idea.
The wake, the wake chat, the funeral service.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't wait to have a Doki Bird sponsored coffin in
Tombstone with it.
It's my, oh my God.
Animies, anime themed funerals.
Like, who wouldn't want to be buried with their own?
I need to stop cooking I'm sorry capitalism's got me I need
to stop cooking JJK funeral coffin oh my god buried with
your favorite anime I mean it won't be copyright
infringement if the copyright holders make merch out of it
they just need to sell their likeness to other companies to
funeral partners who would be like official partner with jjk
like imagine a funeral parlor who literally says official
partner with jjk like imagine that that would be that would
make so much money now ginger thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you partnered with briar's ice cream we kept
the body cold thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you it would make so Okay, you guys might think my idea is
ridiculous, but you know, like, maybe in 30 or 40 years,
this will happen.
It might be dystopian now.
You might think it's dystopian now, but I swear, it's gonna
be a fucking moneymaker.
And, like, in 30 to 40 years, I am, like, if I stop
streaming in 30 or 40 years, but then I see the anime, like,
I see anime-themed funerals becoming real, I'm gonna revive
my dead channel Just to make a video and be like I told you
so And clip this exact moment And be like nobody believe me
I could be a millionaire
I would have been a fucking millionaire But nobody believed
in my idea
so I didn't have the confidence to sell my idea and make
millions of dollars because my chat didn't believe in me in
the first thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
Razzie can't wait to be lowered into my grave in my dokey
themed coffin while the Santa Rude of music plays thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you I am a vicious I know
where capitalism is going next, but you guys didn't give me
the confidence to take this to Shark Tank.
Shanino, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm imagining a waifu artwork on the casket cover, the Aki
style.
Look, if people can marry Hatsune Miku, people can be buried
with Hatsune Miku.
Think about it.
Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At my funeral, can I just have your laugh in the background
as my coffin gets lowered into the crowd.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway.
Okay.
Soundgap here.
It says I am louder.
Okay.
I lowered myself.
Is it better now?
Or should I lower myself a little bit more?
That sounds like a threat.
What?
It's like till death do us part.
Well, like they had, why can't they get buried with Hatsune
Miku?
I don't understand.
And then they can play like Hatsune Miku.
Like world is mine or something for the song all right let's
actually play train sorry sorry this was like a this was a
weird tangent to to get into before train simulator but here
we are train simulator it's not showing up on the screen for
some reason let me make sure it shows up oh my god is this
one of those things where it can't be game captured i swear
to god is this a game that can't be game captured chat oh Oh
my god.
All right, let me double check.
It could be.
It could be one of those games.
All right.
Academy.
Probably the train should have left 18 minutes ago.
Please.
Please show up on the screen.
I just want to play video.
Oh, there it is.
All right.
Nice.
All right, it's up.
All right, guys.
I should totally do this.
All right, I'm already overwhelmed with how, like, all of
this looks like.
Apparently, it's, like, just like Flight Simulator, where,
uh, where, you know, it's super, and it's a very accurate
simulator to, like, driving a train.
So I'm already a bit overwhelmed.
But I do have the Flight Simulator experience.
So I should be able to take the things I learned from Flight
Light Simulator into Train Simulator.
Like how hard can driving a train be?
You can literally only go forwards and backwards.
Like you're on a track.
You're not on anything else.
You're literally on a railroad track.
So like how bad can it be?
Uh, Dr. Cranberry, thank you for Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Here's to the $15,000 train simulator DLC, but got to
collect them all.
Thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God, I forgot to put on a hat.
Give me a sec, guys.
disappear for a little bit i forgot i i forgot to put on my
hat guys i i bought a hat just for this okay give me a sec
how do i do this again i'm a professional okay hat oh there
it is there's my hat okay nice i have a hat guys oh shit
where did my hat go
Okay, I need to be smaller for this hat, though.
God damn it.
All right, there you go.
All right, it looks a little dumb.
Wait, maybe I should just...
Wait, I got an idea.
Okay, you can't see this yet.
You must be like, Doki, what's going on?
We don't know what's happening.
It's okay.
It's...
Trust the process!
All right, there you go.
Did it work?
Wait, it's not even attached to me.
Okay, there we go.
Yes.
All right, don't worry, don't worry.
It's almost done, guys.
It's almost done.
It's a little tiny, but like, it's not about the size of the
hat, chat.
There we go.
Hat, guys.
Everywhere I put it, it looks so stupid.
This is okay.
Okay, maybe, like, it's a hat on top of a hat situation.
Maybe that's it.
There we go.
It's a hat on top of a hat.
there there you go that should be better right maybe a
little bit bigger there we go yeah does that work this this
is i should oh wait you're right guys give me a sec whoever
said that you're you're a goddamn genius you're you're
fucking right guys give me a sec i haven't i have a better
idea i
right now give me a sec okay there we go oh my god all right
all right let's go
hello your conductor is here your train your train conductor
is here but like okay the problem the issue right now is
that I mean am I tall enough to reach the controls that's
the that's the issue right now i hope i'll be tall enough to
reach the controls today a little bit lower okay don't worry
sound guy i got you let me check where my sound is at though
i got you guys 23 minutes and we're not playing the game yet
this truly is the dokey bird experience uh get a box to
stand on wait you're so right you're so right give me a sec
give me a sec guys Box P and G.
Let me...
Crap.
Let me grab...
Let me grab a box right now to stand on so I can reach
the...
So I can reach the controls before we do anything.
Guys, this is very important, chat.
We gotta be sure that I can reach the controls, guys.
We have to be sure about this.
Alright, save image.
I save it?
That's a WebMBP.
What?
How am I going to stand on the box if I don't have a box
PNG?
All right, we're going to grab this random Canadian box
because it's transparent.
Oh my god, it's a web P file.
No!
It's a fake PNG.
Guys, we're going to start the stream soon, chat.
This is very...
I need to be able to see the controls, guys.
Do you guys want me to crash?
trans all right is this free is this a real png or a fake
png this is god damn it i hate the fake png please all my
homies all my homies hate the fake pngs this is real or fake
we're gonna find out oh it's a real png let's go let's got
that so i can go okay i'll put it here and then guys i
ordered a box so i can do this gag there you go
i got my i got my little baby booster all right academy
whoops okay i don't know what any of these trains are
there's too many trains there's like 1500 000 worth of
trains I don't know okay I want to ride the steam train so I
can be like to chew let's use the coal let's destroy the
environment with the coal uh detected they give us super
chat thank you thank you soon when soon this month or soon
this year they give us super chat thank you thank you I want
to I want to ride a steam train and use the coal all right
let's see is that it coal for the coal gods yes all right
here we go this should be good oh my god that's me that's me
that's how i envision myself as oh my god it's beautiful
charcoal as well oh my god that's great welcome back to the
cab of the br4f steam locomotive motive this is more to this
train than simply starting and stopping wait b i need my
controller oh god all right guys i knew i thought i could
just handle this with mouse and keyboard all right let me
plug in my controller okay oh fuck i forgot like this pc i
need to bend all way down plug stuff in all right here you
go all right i'm ready how do i do this how do i whoa am i
going yeah what is that it wait driving a train is so easy
is that it I just...
What am I doing?
Is that it?
All you have to do is press all these buttons?
There's no more buttons.
Oh, I can put my head!
I reached the flat...
Wow, I reached the...
I reached the flat destination.
Oh, my God.
This is so easy!
Wait!
anybody can be a conductor okay all right I think we're
ready for the real deal that's all I needed to know that's
really oh wait you guys can't hear the game oh whoops I
don't know the game was quiet or you guys couldn't hear it
let me check the output real fast guys all right let's see
system guys i told you guys my whole sound system is a mess
right now so oh shit all right let's see system there you go
now you should be able to hear it all right i think from
that i think from that we've like accomplished everything we
need to accomplish uh we're guiding like driving trains so
is there another steam I want to drive another steam train.
Wait, what's that rail fan?
Someone...
Who made this?
Wait, any steam trains?
How do I find steam?
Okay, steam.
I want to use coal.
How do I...
Do it a bullet train?
No, but I want to use coal.
Chocolate and charcoal.
What's the point?
point if i can't use cold trains this game only has one guys
i need to buy a steam train guys all right oh wait that's a
steam blue peter that has to be steam right that looks like
charcoal she wants to ruin the damn ray i'm glad you
understand all right we're gonna we're gonna
Peter and then Let's see, we'll start I think that's it,
right?
Blue Peter Like I said, like what's the worst that could
Happen?
Alright, here we go What's the worst that can happen, chat?
Hello, driver, you're in control For the final leg through
to Holly Head.
Prepare your local.
Oh my God, I learned this.
Go.
Why is it not going?
Go faster.
Hello, goodbye, lady.
Choo-choo train is going forward.
We've done it.
We've done it, guys.
We've done it, dragons.
We're driving a train.
We did it.
Let's look at the other side of the window.
Oh, my God.
Where's my train?
Yes, air pollution!
Guys, I'm just joking.
I'm not actually cheering on the polluted air.
Oh my god, that is a lot of smoke.
Guys, I'm only joking, guys.
I'm not actually cheering it on.
There's a break?
Where's the break?
I don't know what any of these buttons do.
Oh wait, is it this?
100?
What?
is that oh that has to be the break right and maybe we'll do
58 and then oh can we brought down don't worry i got you
wheel slip oh my god is it this what did my wheel slip guys
did i broke my wheel did my wheel die
You see a realistic driving mode legacy mode selected what
did I select Okay, all right, let me bring down the volume
sorry for like sorry for like getting you out of the
immersion guys I need to fix the on you can't adjust the
audio in your main what What do you mean can't adjust the
audio here?
What do you mean?
why can't i just yeah sorry guys sorry sorry for the lack of
immersion just now we'll be back all right we'll be back
with the train services soon all right here i i lowered it
oh shit all right there you go did i
What is this?
Load and unload?
Wait, what is this?
Oh, let's turn on all the lights.
What's this?
Emergency break?
Oh, shit, sorry.
Sorry.
No, stop.
Don't break.
We're going through the tunnels.
I didn't mean to do the emergency break.
don't worry we're burning more coal more coal
it's okay we might have stopped but the coal engine is going
on
it's okay I killed the engine no I'm still walking guys it's
okay I'm still moving forward I'm just making sure I'm
burning all the smoke I'm making sure the environment knows
I'm coming in.
The wind might be losing coal resources, but don't worry my
job here is done.
Choo-choo.
Oh my god, I'm upside down.
I'm rolling in coal!
Yeah!
it's okay if any passengers are sticking their heads out
right now and breathing in all that smoke that's coming out
of the train do not worry your insurance does not cover this
i'm sorry
wait can i collide to another train oh my god is that
possible is does any a train what?
Sorry, I had to tab out.
I'm sorry for the immersion.
I had to adjust the volume.
Wait, what happened to my game?
What happened to my game?
Oh, my game is freaking out.
What is possible?
Oh my god.
There it is.
The smoke is like a, the smoke is like a balloon if you
think about it.
You can run out of coal.
There's no way you can run out of coal.
I own this train.
There's no way.
Where the rails go?
Right there.
I own the rails.
There's no way.
Look at it go.
My beautiful train.
Where?
Where does it say my coal is running out?
I see nothing that says that.
What do I know when I arrive?
This is a long train ride.
Faster?
How do I go faster?
Do I put more coal in?
Wait, A, what's this?
I put more smoke in.
Can I actually go faster?
Put more coal in it!
Somebody shovel more coal!
Alright, lowered it at volume level.
more somebody
all I'm saying is that like I should own the entire core the
entire core industry yay how am I running a water there's
water right here there's no way I can stop my train and grab
the water at the lake How can I run out of water?
This is bad.
The water's low.
How do you know the water's low?
Is it that blue thing right here?
Guys, I think the blue thing right here is my water.
Okay.
Alright, I stopped the coal shoveling.
Oh, I ran...
Whoops.
Guys.
Guys, why didn't you guys stop me?
cause why didn't guys brought more water did i fail i i can
fail wait what oh wheel slip op air wheel slip guys what the
fuck does wheel slip even mean i don't know about this if i
don't know what error i made how do i actually made an error
like what How could I have made an error if I don't even
know what the error is?
That's what I'm saying.
If I don't know what my error is, then like, how do you know
I failed?
Chat.
How would you know?
All right, what's a better train?
That was a bad train.
It wasn't a bad conductor.
It was just a terrible train.
Uh.
I there's no there's no way I could just run out of water
there was literally a lake next to me like how could I run
out of water when there was a lake next to me it was not a
conductor issue all right what's a better train that train
was just garbage recommend me your best trains chat give me
your best trains classic blame it's not a error because I'm
not human you can't say that guys and you if you blame me
then you just hate tomatoes welcome to welcome I bet you're
a vegetarian if you're blaming me you fucking veggie eater
rassy daisy welcome to the dokey train dokey key track train
line.
Whatever you need to do, wherever you need to go, we may or
may not get there.
Razzy Tazzy, thank you.
We're the super cat.
Thank you.
God.
God damn eating, eating my people.
Alright, let's see.
Alright.
What's a better train, guys?
A bullet train?
Aren't those the type of trains that go really fast?
Ooh, I like those.
My game crashed.
I thought I thought we wouldn't have these issues
This must be I think this is an actual game issue There's no
way There's no way I can't Alright Let's go Pick, okay,
people said a bullet train.
Alright, high speed, is this a bullet train?
Is that bullet train?
The high speed train?
There's no, okay, at least like it was, it's super boot up
fast.
Is that the bullet train?
Is your new name wheel, I don't even know what wheel slip
is.
Is that a good thing?
Hockey, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, that's a bullet train?
Okay, this time we'll reach our destination.
I can't run out of water.
one because it's not like coal related it's a bullet train
it's electricity so like where does the water go all right
hello drive just taking over from another driver so please
open up your door and subway train ahead of a departure at
just on have fun how do i open my doors what's this load and
unload sander uh lights what's sander how do i open my door
2d map task log uh couple oh couple what do i do here do i
take these trains off guys i think i should have i think i
should have went to train school
guys i think i think I think I should have went to train
school, guys.
I...
Oh!
I come on to the train!
Guys!
Get on!
Get on the train, everybody!
What's the coupling?
What happens if I decouple it?
Oh, is this like...
Oh, I guess I'm just gonna decouple it because that's what
it was before.
Are you guys on the train, guys?
Are you guys on the train now?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if you're on the train or not.
Guys, get on.
Guys, come on.
Why does nobody want to...
Why does nobody want to get on the train?
Guys.
I don't understand.
There's nobody that wants to sit on my train.
I don't need you guys.
I'll just go straight.
Timeless.
Timeliness, bonus.
Alright.
Choo-choo!
Guys, is anybody else on the train with me?
Guys?
Why does nobody here want to sit on this train?
Come on!
I might be a first-time conductor, but I know what I'm
doing.
Yay!
Tickets!
Anybody got some?
tickets tickets tickets guys beep beep look oh my god
there's like wipers too I can wipe my train guys I don't
understand guys what is this guys we're turning on the
lights wait what if I what does this even do it doesn't even
turn it off okay four lights nice knowing dragons there's
like zero people on this train except for me like it feels
like people don't trust me and i don't know why like oh my
god that's a lot of trains wait what if i can i detach from
the other trains is that possible pick up passengers from oh
i can pick up passengers guys when do i get there arrive at
17 31 oh i'm speeding It's okay.
It's not like I'm gonna crash or anything.
It's a bullet train.
I should be speeding.
What are you going to do?
Deduct more points and revoke my license?
Wait.
Faster!
They can't do jack shit.
Wait, I'm going to make it.
Wait.
Is that where I'm supposed to go?
Guys, is this where I'm supposed to go?
For like my okay is that it is that my first stop that has
to be my first stop right i think i passed it that pass it
where's my first stop i can't read the map guys oh 400 oh
okay it's 400 okay we go faster uh i'm not there guys Yell
at me when I'm there.
We'll go back to fast then.
Not for...
Oh.
Oh, what the heck happened?
Oh, I accident tapped to the next...
Oh, shit.
I accidentally tapped to the...
I accidentally tapped to the next window.
My mouse...
My mouse went to the next window.
Alright, that's okay.
That's okay.
We're still on it.
We're still on the train.
Wait, I can detach?
Wait, can I det...
What's this?
Can't detach from my other trains?
When my other trains are detached?
What does this do?
I don't know what I did.
I pieced some stuff together.
I think it'll be fine, right?
I don't know what this does.
But, like, as a train enthusiast...
Wait, no point?
Oh, okay.
I don't know what it does.
Like, oh, there it is.
Oh, shit!
Why did you guys not do that?
There's a stop!
No!
I told you guys to tell me!
I told you guys to tell me when I need to stop!
Guys!
Why didn't you tell me to stop?
Yo!
Where's my train?
Where am I?
Oh, there I am.
Alright, that's fine.
We'll, like, go backwards.
We'll go backwards.
It's fine.
Emergency breaks.
We can go backwards, right?
Alright.
Go backwards.
We gotta pick people up.
Alright, there we go.
My bad.
we're going don't worry i'm coming there wait i'm not even
there wait i didn't even miss it but what's that station
okay platform eight where's platform eight this is not
platform eight oh this is platform two jk we're going back
for jk i meant platform a guys Sorry.
Sorry.
I went the wrong way.
Forward.
Oh, shit.
I didn't go forward.
Sorry.
For any passengers.
Oh, shit.
There are passengers.
Dragoon 1.
I told you.
I knew it.
I knew my dragoons believed in me.
I knew there were believers.
Who believed in...
Who believed in my dragon?
Oh, look, there's other dragons!
I see you!
Why am I still going backwards?
This is not good.
Okay, I need a break.
I need a foley break, I think.
I need a foley break.
I knew.
I knew it.
I knew you guys.
Trust me.
I knew it.
I knew I'm not a disappointment.
Okay.
And now we go this way.
beep beep see I knew it guys I knew you guys would ride on
my train what is this emergency break engine start look
isn't it beautiful it's like we're on that train together
chat you and I all aboard dark thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you
I I knew not going to train school was a good idea and was a
scam.
I knew train school was a scam all along.
You have passed a signal at danger.
Game over.
What the fuck?
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
Oh, whoa.
It's not.
Speeding was bad.
guys why did nobody warn me about my speeding my drive
quality i was just trying to look at the scene that was just
a bad train that was also a bad train chat like how was i
supposed to like learn if like i'm given like all these bad
trains and like i'm failing because the chains were just not
good.
There you go.
These trains were just terrible trains.
Tutorial.
I learned the controls.
What is there to teach me?
We're going off the rails on this crazy train.
Mia, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like, what else would they need to teach me?
Pelagius.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know, the devs of a simulator are sissies when they
don't show the explosions or collisions.
So you get a super chat.
Oh, this has no rules.
I love no rules.
Okay, that's great.
Guys, no rules time.
How do I...
Okay, these are all my trains.
What's a better train?
Multi-level cab car.
Oh my god, double...
Double the victim.
Yes!
Okay, and then...
Wait, why is there two?
Oh, we need two trains.
Oh, Washington to Baltimore.
Alright, there you go.
Start.
You don't mean it.
Say it again.
What do you mean, say it again?
More people on the train.
Isn't that what we want, guys?
More people on the train?
Alright.
Get on the train.
Guys, get on the train, guys.
it's loading time get on i see you guys slowly walking in
come on guys walk on the train why are you all just standing
there come on guys come on dragons hurry up we don't have
all day dragons hurry up we have plenty of room here uh
andrigos thank you for the five gift the ships thank you
thank you come on guys come on it's double it says double
the fun wait did i did i press the wrong button when it okay
wait no unload load why is it not opening open the doors are
people getting on now i can't tell Are people loading in?
I can't tell.
I can't tell people are going in or not.
Be not afraid.
Oh, there it is.
The doors are opening.
The doors are opening over here.
Oh, my God.
It has an American flag.
All right, here you go.
This is start.
Beep, beep.
Train is about to start, everybody.
Oh, that guy's okay.
This train is packed They fell Stop at Washington Union
Station track Where is that?
Okay guys, yell at me when I'm getting close To Washington
Union station track Alright guys, look I need you guys to
yell at me when I'm close to there Okay Oh shit, my break is
still on Alright, nice There's no rules to stop us
Now nothing can stop us.
Okay, let's still move all the other people.
Oh shit, it's raining.
I should like do the wipers.
There you go.
Whoa, that's a lot of controls.
Whoa!
What does this do?
What does this control?
I put the bell on, but what does the bell do?
I don't like that the light started flashing.
Oh, boy!
Beep!
Oh!
I can't flip those!
Pussies!
Wait, where's my co-pilot?
Where's my co-train?
Wait, what's this?
I acknowledge you.
What does that say?
Okay, I think all of these...
What's this?
Oh, this has to be like...
Oh, okay, we gotta go full speed ahead.
This has to be like...
Oh, that's the release break.
Wait, what's this?
What am I doing?
What is that?
What's that sound?
Guys, I don't know what that sound is.
I heard a sound, but I don't know what that does.
Oh, that's the break!
Oh!
All right.
There we go.
What do you mean, aviation disaster?
That fucking plane was Jesus.
That was no disaster.
I think we're going to be fine.
Let's sit with the people.
Let's let the conductor sit with the people.
Hey, guys.
You guys having a good time?
oh my god look at how fast we're going guys are you hey i
guess heard of that movie like train to busan good things
have always happens on train it was like so popular and
everything and like it has to be a really good movie about
trains then if that movie did really well Also that other
movie about trains where like people like every population
and citizen like um You know wait are we going wait why did
we stop What's going on on the train?
Oh actually stop guys sorry Sorry the conductor accidentally
stopped it because like she's not at the conductor seat
right now But don't worry we're gonna be
Don't worry, everything will be fine.
Local break.
No breaks.
We don't need the breaks.
Wait, why aren't we going forward?
All right, sorry.
I'm going to be back with the train, Pete.
Like, I'm sorry.
I have to do my job again.
Are we...
Wait.
What's going on?
Start.
Start the engine.
Did we run out of power?
Did we...
Yes.
What happened?
That hit something?
There's no way.
Where's the train?
That hit something?
Go forward.
Why aren't you going forward?
Somebody.
Help the train stop going forward.
I have to break.
Breaks are off!
What do you mean?
Okay.
Okay, I got this.
I got this.
Maybe it's this.
It has to be.
Is this causing the whole issue?
Is this causing everything?
Why is it negative?
No.
We have to accelerate.
And then...
Go.
Go!
go guys wait for it guys guys we're on a schedule my train
boss is not going to be happy about this we're not moving
okay it's okay stay calm stay calm you won't get fired it's
your first day
no how did i break it i just pressed What if I put more
sander in it?
I don't know what sander is, but like I'll put more sander
in.
Is that coal?
Put more coal in there.
Do I have gas?
Okay, I have zero power, but like that should be okay,
right?
Oh no.
But like, how do I have zero power when the wipers are
working?
Is it on?
That turn the engines off?
Guys, any train conductors?
Any...
Where are the train conductors?
Guys!
Train conductors, I need help!
Blue lover down.
Oh, down?
Okay.
There.
Whoever is down.
And then what?
Yellow button?
What does the yellow button even do?
I just acknowledge.
Red stick?
Okay.
Alright.
Zero.
Release.
blew up blew up go train go wait wait is my train going am I
moving I'm moving it was the yellow button I don't know what
it was but I acknowledged it and then it like stopped
working I don't know what this is.
It was the yellow button.
We're back online!
Nice.
Okay, I knew it.
Was that the brakes?
Oh, that's the brakes?
Why is it called acknowledge?
I thought it just wanted me to acknowledge it.
Why was it the yellow button?
Alright, nice.
We're back on schedule, guys.
Alright, back with the people.
Hey, guys.
So, like, we had a little... We had a little issue with the
train but like everything will be okay dragoons don't worry
I know what I was doing a dead man switch yeah Dr. Cranberry
think of a super chat thank you thank you the yellow button
allows the train to know you care about it and you love
existence and appreciate yeah that's what I thought I
thought because it was like do you want to appreciate the
train and I was like yeah I appreciate the train like
I don't know what dead man switch is it just says
acknowledge and I was like okay I acknowledge your existence
like how else was I supposed to know that it's supposed to
it's like gonna stop my train I don't have a co-pilot with
me I'm lonely I'm so lonely wait we're so slow who the fuck
And a... Who stopped my train?
Who stopped my train?
Oh, no.
Wait.
Why did it stop again?
Did I acknowledge something again?
Who stopped it?
I left it unattended so it stops.
But I want to be with the people.
I didn't...
I don't think I did that.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Go forward.
Go!
Move!
Okay.
We'll put that down here.
Beep, beep.
Is it the bell?
Maybe I should stop having the bell off.
Or like, no, the bell should be on.
Guys, I stopped moving again.
I stopped.
Guys, I don't understand.
Why did I stop?
I acknowledge you.
Did it work?
Okay, maybe if I turn it on and off.
Maybe.
Okay.
There you go.
button uh a blue lever okay here you go i'm putting it at
zero and then boom oh it's moving in oh no that's just the
rain that's just the rain guys okay maybe okay keep
everything at zero and we're resetting everything guys okay
zero i hope there's no train behind me because That would be
awkward.
All right.
We'll reset it real fast.
Hey, guys.
So we're going to have a little delay.
We're going to, we access, there's like a deer crossing in
front of our train right now.
So like, because I am such a humanitarian and I don't want
to, you know, have bad karma, we're going to let some deers
cross through the train tracks.
And like behind the deers, there's also some geese as well
and a little family geese in front of us as well.
And that is why I delay.
And obviously, like, if you guys want me to go forward, then
you want me to commit animal slaughter.
And you're not that bad of a type of types of people,
dragoons, right?
So that's why we're going to experience some really, really,
very tiny delay, guys.
Just very tiny.
So I hope you all, you guys understand.
All right.
I think they believed it.
Okay.
All right.
That should be enough time, right?
We go forward.
Guys, I don't understand.
guys don't understand why isn't my why isn't my train going
forward train should just go forward maybe turn the brake on
and off again is this the brake yeah that's the brake okay
on i don't know what this is but on and then off.
Is that it?
Am I going forward?
No?
What is this?
Locomotive break.
Is it this?
I only have one engaged?
I have more than one engine.
What's this?
go up
pull it back all right I pulled it back don't worry we know
what we're doing guys are we going forward are we guys I
think we needed the tutorial wait what does this button do
oh it does nothing okay it says emergency you had the
locomotive We're going forward, guys!
Oh, my God!
I don't need school.
Guys, I fucking knew it!
I don't need train school.
Anybody can be a conductor.
There's, like, five buttons.
Chat.
All right, see?
All right.
Hey, passengers.
Luckily, we were lucky enough that the herd of deers and
geese made us, through so we can you know we can get started
everybody we can keep on going to your destination we're not
delayed i'm pretty sure where are we all right where is the
stop we have to stop at track nine i think we're making good
progress that's our train that's our train right there we're
making really good progress we're not late it just is stop
at it didn't say what time I should be there.
Oh, so yeah, guys.
We're making really good progress, chat.
Um, I'm sorry to all the actual train enthusiasts that are
watching me drive this train right now because I know it's
making you feel... How are we stopping again?
Who keeps stopping our train?
Who is it?
Who keeps stopping?
Who's doing that?
I don't understand.
How'd I hit the brakes?
Oh, I'm so sorry.
It was me.
I'm hitting the brakes.
Guys.
It was me.
I was the one that was hitting the break.
No, I don't know how to start the train again.
I touched the lever again, guys.
It was me all alone.
I keep stopping the train, chat.
Who would have thought it was me all alone?
Every time you leave the train, the train alone, he gets
sad.
All the train enthusiasts in my chat yelling at me right
now.
Oh my god, I keep forgetting how to start back the train,
guys.
There should be a key that lets you, like, start the train.
Like, it just, like, kickstarts it.
There should be a key for that.
Like, I just, like, a hotkey where I just press it and then
all the train will, like, go fast.
Logical, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dell, thank you for the super chat.
I can see the headlines now.
Tomato causes double-decker train derailment in Baltimore.
Oh, there's another train!
See, hi to the train sister.
Hello, train sister.
How can he, how can he can drive his train so fast?
And I can't.
What's the difference between his train and my train?
I don't understand woodman thank you the super chat thank
you thank you I send you an email about the scheme I'm
actually locomotive engineer would love to help you all
right what do I do woodman what do I do now why is my train
always so clingy what buttons do I press why is my train
such a clingy little bitch
easy don't break but i'm not going forward guys i'm not
going maybe oh wait wait i i need to unlock it unlock it am
i going forward oh i'm pressing yellow again i pressed the
yellow button i did it it's okay it's okay i don't need it
all right it's okay we did it guys i did it i need to
remember to not hit this button oh my god and there's light
now i'm doing a good job so the game is giving me light guys
i'm doing a good job yay celebratory honk
No, only the train, but I'm so lonely.
It's just me and the train.
I want to hang out with the dragoons and the passenger
seats.
They're playing like Uno right now.
I need to press the button.
Why would I need to press the button?
Every time I press the button, I stop.
Oh, there's cars outside.
Hello, cars.
Welcome.
the other trains?
Where are the other trains in front of me?
There's safety penalties?
There's no safety procedure.
What if I own the train?
If I own the railroad company, because railroad companies
are a monopoly, and it's my turn to drive the train, I
should have zero safety penalties.
I bought the game, so I own this railroad.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you Thank you.
This train reminds me of the train from the Sonic Murder
Mystery Game.
Such clingy trains.
Thank you, Mr. Oh, shit!
It went yellow again.
No!
No, I got the safety penalty!
Stop!
I went over the safe- I can't believe the safety police is
here!
Every time I go too fast, the safety police stop me!
What a fucking loser.
No fun This train won't let me have fun They keep pressing
the yellow button on me Every time Every fucking time
And you hit control D And then control F I can get rid of
the safety procedures That's good We don't need safety here
We don't need to...
I can't believe it!
They keep fucking getting me...
Getting me into the safety zone!
Losing!
Losers!
Goddamn losers!
Boom.
There we go.
I pressed all the buttons again.
Let me drive my train!
we don't need safety what is this signal speed track speed I
can't believe I can't do I can't do like full speed ahead
that's bullshit bro I'm not even close to my stop every time
every fucking time okay Release the brakes!
Release!
Go!
Alright.
Let's see.
Can't believe it!
Fine, we won't go all the way.
We'll do 55.
Are you happy, trade?
I even let you do 55!
You know what?
You don't deserve win wipers.
You don't deserve it.
Yellow then breaks down.
Yellow breaks down.
Go!
Am I going forward?
Am I...
Wait, it breaks are still on?
How?
Is this releasing it?
Local break.
Train break.
Alright, zero.
Go!
Okay.
Oh no.
Come on, I turned it off.
Oh, I have to stop accelerating before I start.
Whoops.
Okay.
Maybe that's it.
Is that it?
Pull both red.
I think I pulled the red already.
Yeah, the red's already down.
oh all the way down okay all the way down are we doing it
guys you you decide to ride on the train instead of taking a
car that's on you you know what you're getting oh he decides
to ride a train
that's on you
police stopped me i can't believe the train police stopped
me fucking train police don't yeah i'm late to work you know
who's driving this train you could have taken a plane or a
car or a metro you could take any other train it's on you
for riding on my train you know it was my first day all
right let's see i'm trying to look the the fucking fun
police stopped my train like four times okay and i still
don't know how to fix this okay everything is off i pressed
the yellow button the yellow button is pressed this off yeah
this is off all right and then there you go Can I go forward
now?
That's not fair!
Forward!
Stupid rules and regulations.
Wait, is that another train behind me?
No.
Okay, I thought there was another train behind me.
That would have been awkward.
No, there's me.
There's me.
Do you guys see me?
There's me over there.
I keep turning the brakes on.
Is this a brake?
Guys, I should have...
Okay, after I head to the destination, I'm going to go look
at the tutorial.
I'm going to look at the tutorial.
I swear.
I'll look at the tutorial.
I just want to get to my destination.
Guys...
Why won't they let me go?
I don't understand why the train would do this.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, let's see.
Alright, red handle up.
All right.
Yellow button.
Throttle off.
What's throttle?
Is this throttle?
Power controller.
Acknowledge.
Boom.
That's it.
Nobody's making to their destination.
Nope.
That's it.
Nobody's gonna arrive to their destination.
We're going back to train school.
We're going
That's looking it you guys all say I'm fucking taking a taxi
and going back to train school You guys can all call an
uber.
I need to figure this out.
All right driving Okay, let's see which one was the train I
was trying all right switching cabs loading passengers
should it just be this all right all right guys okay welcome
to the rail complete each action after closing these
messages and let's learn about switching junctions modern
busy railroads are controlled by remotely by a singling
center dispatcher in freight yards many small and frequent
uh require making automatic control and practical in yards
those the difference between the two types of switches can
be identified by the equipment a manual switch has a lever
to turn it one way or the other an automatic switch has a
small box containing oh my god manual junctions can be
operated by clicking the lever or pressing g they can also
be changed on the action what the up ahead the pass switch
is to the left using the free camera fly over I have to
fucking get off my train and click on the lever?
What do you...
What do you mean?
What do you mean I have to click on the lever?
That's fucked up.
Wait, we should go for it.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're going for it right now, right?
co-pilot guys it's okay I have a co-pilot that's gonna help
me it's gonna help me guys it's okay wait where's the lever
where's the lever oh here oh god guys I missed the lever
guys it's okay I pressed it now I did it
Guys, it worked, guys.
Guys, I think I did it.
I reached it.
It said I reached it.
Guys, it said I reached it, so I assume I did it correctly.
Oh, I can, like, learn how to load an unknown.
Alright, guys, we reached our...
Okay, this is when we pretend we reached our destination.
We reached our destination.
Welcome back.
We learned how to pick up passengers.
Oh yeah, I'm familiar on how to stop.
A land passenger.
We're approaching the station.
Bring the train to stop alongside.
Okay.
There we go.
Are we slowing down?
Wait, are we there yet?
Oh shit.
Okay, guys, sorry.
We're gonna have to keep going.
Whoops.
We sort of stopped a little bit.
Sorry, guys.
The train is experiencing a small delay.
Sorry, I stopped a little bit too early.
Don't worry, we're going back.
See, there's me!
We're starting again.
Don't worry, guys.
I know how to do this for real.
It's okay.
Sorry, I didn't really...
realize where the train stop was.
Oh my god, there's people there.
There's people that believes in the Doki train.
They heard they heard I was gonna be here.
Wait, stop.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I'm still in.
I'm still in.
Sorry.
This is a little... I'm still in, guys.
See?
They heard!
Allow passengers on board.
Switch to an external reveal and click on the path form or
press Oh, wait, I was supposed to Oh, I was definitely not
boarding People Oh, my Guys, I was definitely not Letting
people in my Train in the beginning, guys I just realized
The people in my Train from before were just trapped In
there
The people There were in the other train was definitely just
trapped in there from a previous ride i definitely took them
somewhere that they were not supposed to be all right we
learned guys we're learning we're learning uh objectives
okay we don't need to know these so we don't have water so
controls all right Primary control.
What?
Electric, right?
No.
What were some of the actual good trains?
Okay.
Has to be like this one.
This one.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, we're gonna learn the controls, guys.
Back to train school, we go.
This is a cab of a class.
The camera will change view.
Each control is set correctly.
Okay.
You need the direction power.
Direction is controlled by the reverser.
Push this all the way forward.
This train has combined power and brake levers.
Sat in the middle, power is neutral.
To start, pull the lever towards you to 3.
3.
That's 57.
Oh, I should not put it on 100 then.
Yay!
Oh my god, there's safety!
There's a safety thing behind me.
It's not safe.
Oh, it's not safe.
Oh, shit.
Yay!
Put it all the way.
Max it up.
I don't know what that yellow button did, but I pressed it.
I still don't know what it does.
I think I'm doing a pretty good job.
It says full power.
power guys the main speed we don't need any power in coast
push the lever to off every system may have it so a low
setting may be required ah so fun how about my dragons have
fun how
would they have fun if the power is off you'll think it's
boring oh my gosh they won't let me look at the passenger
they won't even let me i want to stop push the lever slowly
forward until the camera resets close this message box what?
Slowly forward until it resets oh, all the way up oh, okay I
can't interact with the passengers, it won't let me it's
like they knew what I did in 1975 okay, alright nice,
alright Wait, that's so easy.
Wait, all of this is so easy.
So, like, did I learn enough?
What else do I have to learn?
What else do I have to learn, chat?
I don't understand.
Try the other train?
But I learned everything.
I learned everything, though.
What else do I need to learn?
Driving again?
Wait, where's driving?
What do you mean?
It's switching junctions and switching cabs.
We don't need to know that.
We already know how to...
Okay, I think we're fine.
Alright, as long as there's no safety, we're fine.
Okay, quick drive.
Okay, custom.
Oh, I can...
Can I create my own train?
Okay.
Oh my god, I can create my own train.
Bro, this is where all the fucking nerds go.
I just threw that.
Alright, no engine found.
Where the fuck is an engine?
There.
Add to front.
It's incompatible?
It's just what?
No engine.
God.
Okay.
Oh, it's wet.
Oh, wagon.
Diesel.
Electric.
Okay.
Maybe we can just add this.
There you go.
Name.
Dragoons.
Save.
All right.
Where did my Dragoon car go?
Where is it?
I created a Dragoon car.
I can't believe it.
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
nice all right uh let's start uh no rain that sucked that
shit fucking suck wait free roam if i like do free roam does
that mean like oh wait can i actually no i can't oh i don't
have i don't have the uh it's only the end the engine is all
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
We need, like, we need people in it.
All right.
How do we add people into our train?
Okay, is that the wagon?
I want to add people to our train.
I need you guys to sit in my train.
Okay, add.
Okay, no.
Add back.
Delete.
It's incompatible?
How?
I want people on my train.
wait that must be it no how is it incompatible okay guys
guys i might guys i don't know if you guys notice this but i
might not be i might not be a train expert guys is it
noticeable
guys is it noticeable that i don't know what i'm doing
can you tell guys can you guys tell oh okay add to the front
oh there you go what if i want to add a different part of
this car okay insert oh all right there you go there we go
this is it we got it okay next this is the better dragoons
all right here we go we did it we have a new dragoon car all
right and then uh all right we have like passengers for
passengers no i want like you're right i should add more
cards oh my god you're right guys wait you're so right guys
we're going back we're going adding more cars into this
you're right whoever gave me that idea you're a genius more
people should be on my train all right let's see cabin
passenger car insert oh it doesn't work oh it has to be an
electric okay motor car is that right add to the back oh and
then we'll have what's this we need more passenger seatings
okay add to the back no wrong one add to the back of this is
there like cat or is there a way oh okay no that's just the
regular stuff alright let's just keep adding how many can I
add
alright we can keep going can I make a really long car
can I just make it super long I think I can add to the back.
nice.
There's no problems.
Oh my god, okay.
I'll keep adding more.
I mean, there's no problems with it.
Alright, nice.
For all you 700,000 dragoons!
Of course!
Nice.
Alright, here we go.
I think we're good now.
I think we can do this.
How many wag?
I don't even know.
I just kept pressing button.
Does that spend my entire gameplay?
I just keep pressing.
Oh, it's still going.
Guys, it's too long.
Guys, I think it's too long.
Okay.
Okay, we got to fix the trick.
eight okay uh no fun guys okay let's start let's start
deleting guys what's the what's the maximum amount that i
can have okay okay maybe that's better is this better now
train gods is this better now and spawn off the tracks all
right now now it should work yeah all right here we go train
cars is this better now i can't believe it dragons you gotta
stop derailing the train i don't think it's my fault i think
the drag there was just too many dragoons on the train that
it got derailed i think that's it there's no way way bro how
can they be like derailing it's like four okay there we go
one two three four all right four passengers that should be
enough all right there you go okay now we can go on the
chain the long gun is too long there we go i like how it
won't even let me see the train anymore.
I'm just looking at the top of the roof.
I can't believe it!
Why?
Why do I keep derailing?
There's been trains that were that long?
It's not even that long anymore!
It's literally three trains!
Guys, this is a scam.
It's literally four trays long how is that too long okay
there we go longest trade is almost yeah like it's not even
that bad can i see the roof now oh okay now i can all right
at least there's no guys there's no more derailments guys i
made it i didn't i did not derail oh hey all right guys guys
all aboard All aboard!
Get on my train!
Come on, this guy looks like he's having fun!
Look at the excitement on this guy!
No, no, we're not closing.
Come on, come on, guys.
Come on.
Come on, I don't care.
As many passengers in as possible, guys.
There's no timer.
Come on, I know you guys want to.
All aboard.
No, no, no.
We're not closing the doors.
Sir, I know you want to get on this train.
Dragons, I know you want to get on.
Oh, y'all, look, they're getting on.
Alright.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, don't worry, red shirt.
Don't worry, red shirt guy.
There you go.
Don't worry.
I got you, red shirt guy.
I got you guys.
Alright.
Now we start the train.
Okay, I learned.
It was like this at 50 and then boom.
There we go.
Why don't we start?
Oh.
There we go.
We did it.
Wait, what's the horn for this?
Oh, it's like the switch.
Whee-oh.
Where do we have to go?
Let's see.
Let's look at our map.
We need to stop at that.
LAMSEC.
Where are we?
LAMSEC 2.
Where's our ride?
We're all the way here.
So, I mean, that's a particularly long ride.
Can't be that bad.
Eh.
Okay, I think there's no more safety precautions, so we're
fine.
Right?
Let's make sure there's no safety.
I think we'll be fine.
let's take our head out look at that guys we're doing so
well at this time oh shit how do i get closer oh shit that's
not what i want no my train is moving away no train oh there
we go there we go nice all right i just wanted to like ride
with the people look at you guys i see you guys over there I
see you guys.
Whoa.
You guys having fun?
Are you guys?
Oh my god, there's a full family in there.
Are you guys having fun family?
What about we're here?
Nobody here?
Where are the people?
Oh, look another family!
Hey guys.
Oh no, never mind.
She's alone.
Wait, there's birds too!
I think I'm doing a great job.
Now that I'm not going full speed ahead, nobody can stop me.
You know what?
I'm feeling so wild.
Look, and then there's me!
There's me!
I'm right here!
Guys, that's me!
On my train skin suit.
You know, driving a train ain't that hard.
Don't know why people were freaking out earlier about it.
Okay, I'm over here, and we have to stop all the way over
here?
No, wait.
Wait, where's LAMSAC?
Where's LAMSAC 2?
Wait a minute.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, it's all the way here.
And I am...
Where again?
Oh, shit, we're almost there.
Watch the...
Another train's not gonna hit us, guys.
We're fine.
No other train's gonna hit us.
We're so safe.
Chad, all the train training has saved us for this occasion,
guys.
Our train training has led us to this.
We went to school for it.
So we'll be fine.
I can't believe someone's, I can't believe people buy DLC
for this.
Sorry.
Like, how different is the DLC?
How different is the DLC, like, between trains?
Because, like, I bought the deluxe version because I wanted
more trains.
didn't fake a train in joy.
Wait, that pat- there's no way I passed it.
I guess if like the train is like particularly interesting,
I can see that.
No, I didn't pass it.
Where is it though?
It's like right- oh, it's right here.
I didn't pass it.
I'm like so not even close to it, I think.
Wait.
Yeah, no, I'm not close to it at all.
It just adds more trains, but do they just- do they look I
mean to be fair I feel like okay not gonna lie I feel like
this buying train DLCs for this is cheaper than owning like
those like mini trains you know those train sets oh wait no
I can understand now train enthusiasts go fucking hard like
the train collect I watched young Sheldon so sorry that's
like sort of my point of reference but like I watched young
Sheldon and he's like a
so like so like I I can I remember and then I remember in
back in the day back it's a good show you can okay big bad
theory that was like you know but like but like young
Sheldon is actually really decent okay you guys just laugh
because you've never watched young Sheldon.
You've never watched young Sheldon so you don't understand.
It's just like a family.
It's like a family wholesome show.
It's not always about Sheldon.
Guys, there's other characters in young Sheldon.
Anyway, anyway, I know that train enthusiasts go like super
hardcore, but like so like I know like there's like train
conventions too so like you know there's like anime
conventions there's like train conventions and and like how
close is the station I don't know how close am I to the
station oh no that's not the station I went slower because I
thought I was gonna miss it oh I'm almost there I'm almost
there guys and like people like you know build those like uh
uh model train sets and like those like miniature train sets
I do wonders though if like the general population for like
train enthusiasts is dying I feel I wonder I wonder if
zoomers are feel you know how like like some interests are
considered like for like you know like not the young so
except for young Sheldon but so I do wonder if there's like
enough new blood to replace the audience like the consumer
base for uh for train collectors Because, like, I know
there's, like...
I don't really see much about it anymore, like I do in the
past.
We're almost there!
Oh my god, we're gonna get to our first destination, guys!
It's happening!
Chat!
We're gonna...
We're gonna get to our first destination!
Oh my god, we're almost there.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we can slow down!
We're getting good at this game!
wait where's my train guys i don't know why i'm slowing down
in time guys i don't guys i'm a little worried guys i'm a
little worried i'm not slowing down i'm not slowing down
enough guys i'm a little worried guys i think we're gonna
miss our stop guys i'm guys i'm not slowing down guys i'm
not slowing down guys i'm a little worried guys i'm not
slowing down in the stations i'm ahead of me No!
No!
Oh, I reached it.
I did it.
Yeah.
We did it, Chad.
We did it.
Never punished.
Woo!
Yippee Guys we did it guys We stopped at our destination
Chat We're such good And then the game crashed I think it's
the game Wait okay alright alright Alright we'll do one more
We'll do one more Suggest me a train DLC Suggest me a train
DLC guys It has $15,000 worth of trains What DLC should I
try to get guys for the train sim that's what i'm saying i'm
saying this has to be cheaper than like the train sets and
stuff so like i now i sort of understand why there's like so
many dlcs because like if you wanted to just own one of the
trains you can just i am not this is literally train
simulator 2024 what are you talking about how is there more
i mean there's train sim world sim world there's train what
the fuck is train Siberian railway simulator wait I should
have played this game what the fuck wait what the fuck is
this all right guys we're gonna like uh I'm gonna buy this
right now I'm gonna buy train Siberian all right guys we're
cool you thought the ride was over there's a surprise game
there's a surprise game oh my i saw i saw wait it released
like on 30th may i literally saw this game while looking up
train dlcs but like guys new game alert guys
give me a sec guys i'm installing it don't worry guys guys i
checked the it is 24 gigabytes not be well optimized i
refuse to believe this game is surprise surprise second game
guys we're gonna be playing something called trans siberian
railway simulator i saw 10 seconds of the gameplay footage
where i shot shoot a bear and then i was like wait
Wait a minute.
Then I got curious.
I got curious.
Trains and guns?
Oh my god.
Okay, we're gonna, we have a little delay here.
It still has to do with trains though.
Don't worry, trains are still involved.
Alright, before that, let's go back to the other train DLC.
Train simulator classic.
favorite.
My train enthusiast.
Which trains are your favorite trains?
It might make me buy your train.
This is it.
This is your chance.
Train enthusiast.
To tell me your favorite train.
What's this?
T train simulate.
my god what is this isn't this like the how is that a trains
we're not spending 15 000 on a train train on train dlc guys
guys 15 000 i can buy so many other things i can drop by
multiple things chat we're not spending 15 000 this is not
where our investments go wait you know thomas the tank
engine what kind of train is that is there a train simulator
train a Thomas the tank engine guys trade enthusiasts what
kind of train is Thomas the tank engine a tank okay mr.
fucking fancy pants a tank it okay he must have like an
actual train name okay yes I know he's a tank engine but
like what kind of tank engine like yes i know he's a king
all right what's the closest thing on e oh my god you guys
actually okay do i have the e2 locomotive e2 locomotive mr
ashley no what do you mean how am i supposed to fucking
drive Thomas the tank engine.
An absolute weak lady.
Oh my God.
I need my real train enthusiast.
Do they have the DLC of it though?
Like that's all I want to know.
Do they have the DLC?
Someone telling me if Thomas the tank engine has a similar
DLC.
That's all I want to know.
Type O6OT.
O6.
O.
T.
Okay, what the fuck did you like made me type?
That was nothing to do with trains.
Okay.
No!
All I wanted was to drive a Thomas the tank engine.
That's all I want.
Bacord and find a simulator that simulated Thomas's train.
I can't believe it.
I was willing to spend money i'm driving it the thomas the
tank engine it might not have been fifteen thousand dollars
but it was close enough
i could have almost spent something similar to 15k but i
couldn't find i couldn't find the right train No!
Try the Fowler 4F logo.
Guys, my train enthusiast, you're all failing me right now.
Guys, guys, I thought you knew all of- I thought you knew!
I thought you knew about- I thought you knew if they were
trains that looked like it!
Okay, Fowler Ooh, Fowler 4K, 4F Loco.
I mean, I guess it looks like Thomas the tank engine.
Oh, okay, we'll try that.
All right, I just want to look at it.
Okay, I'm paying for it.
I bought it.
All right, okay, you're right.
We all fell each other.
Guys, I'm installing the update.
All right.
All right, don't worry.
I'm sorry for ever doubting you, my train enthusiast.
I'm sorry for ever doubting you guys It's okay we found him
We found him We found Thomas Guys We found Thomas guys
Alright It was like $9 Okay Now that I said it out loud That
was a lot That was a lot for a train skin Now that I said
that Okay maybe it was Maybe Maybe it was not the best idea
to buy that.
Wait, where's my train?
What the fuck is my train that I paid money for?
Is that it?
I bought this one, right?
I bought this one.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
There's so many trains.
There's so many things parked.
of this train what the fuck all right that's a lot there's
no face on it though it's okay we can we can pretend oh my
god what the fuck guys i did not learn how to drive this
train i did not okay it's okay things will be okay all right
guys we all right who wants to ride train.
Oh, the, what the fuck?
This is not fair.
This is actually not the British Railways in like, is this
like in, where are we?
Is this German?
Is this?
Why are we here?
We're not playing a Thomas song.
I don't want to get copyright.
I don't want to share my revenue with fucking a bpc right
now this is not fair how come this train can be so long and
then my train got like was too long i can't believe it okay
it feels so wrong to have a british train here in germany
right now but like like how did it get here how did thomas
how did you get here thomas
There should be no safety For this one I refuse to but oh
wait Fuck there's we need water God damn it Oh the horn
might be cool We have the classic horn Choo choo Best nine
dollars I spent
Choo choo Choo Yay
That's okay if we derail we derail real god this is such a
slow train oh no how far do we have to go oh this is such a
slow train okay stop at causewick platform four where am i
okay it's not that bad causewick is here and i'm like over
here it's not that bad I thought...
Okay, but like the train is fucking slow.
Like I...
Like this is...
It's... It's... It's getting there.
It's getting there.
It's very lower accurate, but...
But like, you know...
It's getting there.
A better train or from...
Than two trials, am I right?
Zero, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay.
Wait, can I put more...
Cool.
blower sander more more blow it up i want more steam coming
out of that hole okay there's a reason why i fucking shipped
this train to germany i want more steam guys we're running a
water i don't think we're gonna make it
there's no passages here it doesn't matter if all i'm saying
is like if we run out of water we'll just abandon the train
in the middle of the railway it's it's the government's
problem after that it's not my problem i'm a private train
owner wait no railways are monopolized never mind whoever
whoever i don't know if the government in germany owns the
railway but like whoever owns this railway it's their
problem not mine oh shit at my brakes were on is that why i
was so slow that would make sense i think no i'm just
equally as slow it doesn't matter it does guys it doesn't
matter i'm so fucking slow it doesn't matter oh the water is
going down Am I closer?
Am I getting closer?
Where am I?
Show task.
Oh, we are.
We are not making it, guys.
We are absolutely not making it, guys.
There is.
There is a long way.
You know what?
We might as well use up all the water.
We might as well.
There's no other choice, guys.
There's no other choice.
If we run out, we leave the train here.
somebody quick shovel more coal somebody down over there in
like i don't know train number 10 train number 10 shovel
more coal dragoons shovel more we need to get to where
causeway platform four guys this train is moving even slower
i can't believe it we're at a solid 12.5 miles per hour
right now it doesn't it doesn't matter how if i could put
that lever to 150 like it wouldn't matter we're at a solid
oh my god we're going up it's 14.7 guys guys we made it
We're at solid 16.3 now.
This is it.
Choo-choo.
Choo.
Faster.
Oh my god, guys.
We're over the speed limit.
It says 10.
But we're at 20.2 because we don't give a fuck.
We don't care.
Can it get any higher?
Because I don't think so.
Because we're at 30% water.
But it's okay.
The closer we get there.
The closer we can like just leave the train.
23.5.
It's slowly going up guys.
It's slowly going up.
Where are we?
Wait, we might be able to make it.
Guys, we might be able to make it.
Look.
That's the train.
That's where we need to get it.
Guys, I think we need to get it.
think we can do it.
Guys, I think we can do it, guys.
Pressure is dropping.
Where's the pressure?
What do you mean?
What do you mean by pressure?
Is this pressure?
PSI?
Is that what pressure stands for?
You guys sit here, like a...
Oh, hey.
This train is so up in the front right now.
We can't believe this train can have, like, 20 fucking
cards, and I can't...
And I can't have, like, six passenger cars just because i
have people in mine like like who cares
like so what if i have people in my train and they won't let
me add more oh wait i have a co-pilot what the are you what
about this old man on my train running low on water that's a
good time for me to ditch this train It's all right.
If we run out of water, it was just meant to be.
I mean, we literally shipped this a British Railway train.
Steam British Railway train to Germany.
We are not keeping this train.
Oh, yeah, the coal shubbler.
That's the dragon who's shubbling coal.
That's you guys.
That's you.
Yeah, I'm talking about you, dragon.
Yeah, that one dragon over there.
I'm talking about you.
Yes, you.
You get the job to be a coal shubbler.
congratulations guys we don't we're not making it we have
seven percent we have we have seven percent left guys we're
so close to that was the that's the worst part we're so
close this train was never no that train was never meant to
head there all right guys now we're gonna head to Siberia.
We're gonna head to Siberia now.
I need to know what this game is.
I need to know.
Guys, we're gonna head over.
Yes.
We're gonna head to Siberia.
New game.
It still trains.
So it still counts.
Guys.
It still has to do with trains guys i got curious okay okay
i don't know if sound guys still alive but we have a new
thing to balance for you all right let's see video graphics
borderless windows hell yeah fps no why don't we not have
unlimited fps for whatever this game is i don't know what
this game is but what if we don't do that all right sound
guys sound guy we need you more than ever
all right all right let's see all right and we just wanted
to i just wanted to punch a bear on a train play with
survival play with l imagine locomotive a come all right
we're gonna complete missions for the mafia What kind of...
Okay, okay, now...
Okay, now...
Okay, now I'm curious.
What the fuck is the story mode?
Alright.
What is this?
It's still train related, technically.
Hello.
What the fuck?
I have to go to the shop.
I have money.
Oh, Billy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck is this?
I have flashlights?
Where the fuck?
What is this?
Oh my god, there's bread.
There's a knife?
What am I gonna do with a knife?
I thought I'm just driving a train.
Oh, I have to go to the mafia shop.
Not the regular shop.
What is this?
It's Siberian train simulator.
So I got curious.
Oh my god, do I...
Wait, where do I have to go?
You are at the...
In the lower... You can see the status of your money.
In the lower right, on the top level of your characters,
make sure they're on the right level.
statutes it will result in death pay special attention to
the appropriate level of alcohol as its absence leads to a
constantly worsening hangover the illness that increases
after sustaining injuries make sure you buy enough food and
beverages to survive until the next store oh my god okay
okay i guess all right it was time to buy some what the fuck
is Sprats.
All right, I'll buy Sprats then.
We don't need lights.
We just need alcohol.
Okay, milk, banana.
Okay, we'll have...
And then we'll also buy bread.
Oh, we'll buy rye bread.
All right.
Okay, we have food.
Eating time.
All right, there you go.
Okay, it's time.
We got this.
I don't know what game I got us into, guys.
know it says it still has train related stuff so press i to
open more oh my god that's a lot of inventory go to your
locomotive all right it's time to head to my train i'm going
to head to my train now my train is so far why is my train
so far but the oh i have to go up the stairs to get to my
train okay guys we're all here for the train part
we're just here for the train part guys all right
hypothermia what what's temperature oh shit minus 29 degrees
oh that is cold god damn Siberia is cold holy fuck all right
here we go all right I wish I could run faster though
because all I want to do is drive my train that's all that's
all I wanted to do at first do you just enter the locomotive
door oh okay wait they're speaking russian oh headlight
frame small bro i don't need any of this i'm here to get on
my train okay i opened it how do i guys how do i get on my
train guys guys Oh, okay, there we go.
All right.
Oh, then these are like the train parts and everything.
Oh, my God.
I can actually look behind me.
All right.
Battery cord.
Oh, there we go.
I learned all of this.
Guys, I learned all of this.
The main handle.
We move this.
Wait, stand by the side mirror and press E.
Your inspection mode and improves the function of the status
of the train navigate.
Oh, I have to make sure the train is okay What the fuck
train simulator didn't teach me this?
How am I supposed to know if my train's okay?
Oh shit, okay, okay guys I thought I was ready train
simulator teach me I think it looks okay locate the broken
part and add the adjustable wrench to my inventory oh
there's a broken part here what is this is this a mirror oh
it's a speedometer bro what the fuck okay I have to grab the
speedometer apparently I need to fix the speedometer okay is
that for free do you understand locomotive operations
switching procedures and signal meanings yeah thank you for
the super chat thank you yeah and screw the screws of the
what why did a train simulator teach me any of this I just
know how to press like two buttons so Sometimes three.
Put away...
Sometimes three if I feel like adventurous, you know?
Oh my god, I'm also an engineer?
Okay.
Put a new speedometer in the empty space.
You can hold the right mouse to move.
I have a new speedometer?
What the fuck is my speedometer?
I'm also a handyman?
Oh, it's over there.
I don't know why I shouldn't.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bro, it's $60.
The mafia's gonna fucking kill me.
And I'm still trying to repair my train.
I thought I was ready.
I thought the fucking train simulator prepared me for this.
I know I had to do all of this shit.
Okay, we don't need banana.
We need...
Okay.
Boom.
and then tighten the screws up all right here we go we're
tightening the screws up all right you can sell used parts
at the courtyard remember to expect conditions of them
replace them oh we can finally start the train all right
turn on a small compressor switch in the engine room in the
second section of the small what What?
I don't want to get...
I need a crew for this.
What do you mean?
A small...
I have to go to another cabin?
Okay.
A small engine room switch.
Guys, this is more of a train simulator than a train
simulator.
Okay.
Because I'm actually doing something on this train.
I'm so pumped just a one-man train conductor.
Where do you find...
I'm just so good.
Compress air essentially for safety, banking efficiency, and
overall locomotive performance.
The small compression provides pressure.
Bro, simply repair an entire train.
It's so easy, bro.
Rusty corn.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Pantograph is an apparatus mounted on a roof of an electric
locomotive to collect power through contacts with.
Oh, my God.
I'm actually learning what these things are.
That thing up top, that's called a pantograph.
I'm learning, guys.
Turn on the panda grass power switch on the cut.
Oh my god Okay window heating I need heat Okay field
generator compressor engine cooling High speed Panda crab 1
panda crab 2 power KVC oh my god
okay we got that there's more buttons okay okay electricity
the red light shows the electricity turn on pantograph one
and two okay that's main circuit armature circuit okay turn
on the heating first set and heating second set there's more
buttons to the side okay signalization heating break heating
second set break cap okay handles heating lip button what
the fuck is measuring apparatus illumination oh okay lights
on the on the dials okay light dial lights okay first
section second section reservoir venting what the fuck do i
need a button i need a vent for what's this what are there's
a manual Oh, my, oh, my God.
Wait.
There's so much.
Oh, my God.
Take this look.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Wait, what?
I just saw a god bear.
What do you mean?
This is more of a fucking train simulator.
Okay.
All right.
All right, keep the doors and windows closed.
Okay, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Closed.
Oh, I need to close the door.
I need to close the door.
Now I'm letting the heat out.
Close the door!
Ugh.
I gotta make sure I keep the heat in.
Oh my god.
This is what train simulator taught me.
All right.
Turn on the radio.
Is this the radio?
At least I have the radio.
All right.
Can we go on the train now?
This was information for your Karen.
You can press the call button to listen.
Hello?
Alright.
Now what?
Okay.
Next step is to turn...
My engine's not on yet?
Where you at?
My engine's not on!
Oh, the compressor.
Okay.
Compressor switch.
Alright.
Nice.
We're turning it on.
Okay.
And then that starts to control it for the...
Oh my god.
KVC needs to be reset.
How do I...
Oh, here.
Alright.
Okay, it means it's working.
That's good.
Turn on the BV1.
Oh god, okay.
I turn it on.
Okay.
And then BVS, what did I do?
I don't know.
What the fuck is this?
And the red light in the second row means that the engines
are turned off.
We lower them and then raise them up.
Remember we set the...
I am not going to remember any of this!
Oh my god!
The turn on the... Guys, I found another game for train
simulator enthusiasts, guys.
shoot a gun it's located above the entrance in the cabin
what oh it's up here where is it what is this turn on the
video to activate the locomotive control system holy shit is
this all the buttons guys i'm not gonna remember this guys
at least.
Well, turning on the VU.
This is the VU, right?
Okay, we always need to turn this on.
Turn on the specialization system.
Go to the engine room in the... Oh, okay, the engine room is
here.
Okay.
Yeah.
How do I turn it to the forward?
How do I?
How do I do that?
My arms!
Oh.
Oh, there it is.
No, that's not what I do.
Guys.
Guys, I can't turn it.
Oh, there.
Wait.
How did I do that?
Guys.
Guys, my biggest issue, I can't turn this.
I can't.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, okay.
Nope, I went the wrong way.
That's not it.
Okay.
Go forward.
Forward!
Oh, there I did it.
There, I did it.
Nice.
On the left, in the first section.
Okay, and then turn on the attention control.
Are we going yet?
Sun.
Pay close attention.
But, to, but, oh.
Oh, that's the attention.
that's it is that's the tension button green light means
that the movement is allowed up to 60 i need alcohol i need
a fucking i need vodka this russian needs vodka right now
all right it means that you gotta slow down before i'm not
gonna remember all of this we're just gonna head to the next
destination that's like my main goal the moment i get to a
destination i'm happy like i'm literally like starving and
and like almost hung over right now and like i need water
and everything and i'm still trying to figure this out white
light means that the nearest rail signal has not been
detected and you have to proceed next step is to prepare the
break which is used plenia fill the arrow break system of
the locomotive the system utilizes so slowing down to break
a locomotive a different break it will be discussed it'll be
discussed later what do you mean it will be discussed later
This is not looking too good for Doki
Yes, and this is not looking too good
Set the handle main break handle to release okay, I don't
know if I can do all of that but okay
I don't know what any of these mean, but okay You can break
longer and harder.
Okay, position, release, and charge.
Okay, set the main brake handle to the service position.
There we go.
All right, there we go.
Okay, there we go.
Reach the value.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my, this should be like, after you master train
simulator, you get to do this.
That should be like, this is like the true test of your
train knowledge.
Like, you learn everything from the train simulator, and
then you go straight.
into Siberia like I'm just I bet all the train enthusiast
knows what they're what what I'm doing right now I think
they know what I'm doing I don't know what I'm doing oh my
god I'm gonna fucking drink my milk I'm gonna drink my milk
I'm too I'm sad I'm sad I need to drink my milk Alright here
we go Oh service There we go We're still talking about the
break situation Press F to continue Okay if you would like
to Send more prayer okay I don't care But if our fucking
train can't break It's fine train go insert the second go to
the cabin in the second oh my god let me through i need to
go to the second cabin i need to go to the second cabin why
do i need to go to the second cabin let me through okay is
this the second cabin oh no here you go this has to be the
second cabin right this is it wait this is connected wait a
minute this was connected the entire time i didn't have to
go outside oh my god there's a
there's more than this okay all right there's a bad side
okay set the handle breaking out to handle breaking release
position and deactivate it is it not here oh there's that
what is this
okay return to the okay i can close this then all right well
we figured out there's a second side to the that this train
was connected all the line I did not have to Oh set the
handle to blocking Oh my god to go back You want to go back
Where was it Set the Wait blocking handle to handbrakes Oh I
did Can I not do that?
Or I have to do it on the other side Oh it's on the other
side There's two sides I'm getting disoriented There's too
many sides There's too many sides Okay, here.
Okay.
My God, there's too many.
I thought this was going to be a shooting game.
Instead, I get more accurate train simulator.
Set the handler to M.
M.
Okay.
Is this the right M?
Oh, this is M.
Sorry.
There's M bracket R.
Set this to...
one okay there we go if you apply too much power the white
light on the right panel appear in the wheel will not be you
have to reduce the power next step is to connect to the
marked railway wagon drive forward until you pass the
correct railway switch don't try too fast you have to break
soon okay am i driving what if i just go a little faster
there you go Oh my god, I'm going!
I'm going forward!
Guys, I'm doing it!
We're doing it, guys!
Oh my god, we finally figured it out.
Oh my god, wait, I can play a cassette player?
Oh my god, there's so many things.
Okay, we gotta put this to zero so we can...
Wait, it's so far.
So we're in.
Okay.
You're right.
Crank it.
No, we can't.
It won't let me.
It actually stops me.
All right.
Where's the train button?
The whistle button.
There has to be a whistle button here, right?
All right.
Don't worry.
Oh, we have to slow down now.
We have to slow down.
No!
Oh, shit.
The door is open.
Whoops.
Guys, I fucked up, guys.
Guys.
We drove past it, guys.
Guys, I don't...
Guys.
Guys, we drove past it, guys.
Okay.
I have an idea.
Break applied.
Locomotive.
Where's the locomotive?
Where is it?
I forgot which one it is.
Guys, we're so far.
Oh, there it is.
All right.
We did it.
Wait for the train to stop.
And then we go on reverse.
This is what it taught me.
All right.
And then wait for the train to stop.
Okay, the speedominaries go.
I was set up for failure.
Go outside and change the railway road.
Are you fucking kidding me?
It's so far.
I drove...
No!
It's even further!
It's making me walk!
I drove too far!
It's making me walk.
like I'm mad oh I can't punch you never mind excuse the
train wait I can just reverse the train oh my god you guys
are so smart let me run back to my train let me run back to
the train I don't know the tutorial was like go outside and
I'm a sheep so I was like okay I'll go outside outside and
run back to the train.
Wait, can I drive from here?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Everything changed.
Wait, it won't let me, guys.
Guys.
Guys, I can't move any of the buttons because it wants it
wants me to run i have guys it's making me run
no wait i don't have to okay wait maybe i'm just stupid i
just don't know enough about trains oh i have to do the
brakes on the other side okay i got this guys my train
everything is like running out right now my train but it's
okay all right we gotta figure this out guys okay i don't oh
what's this what was that attention guys it's not letting me
guys it's actually not letting me play the
guys i can't move anything i think wants me to run back no i
can't move anything it actually wants me to run back no no
we no guys I can't guys it doesn't matter I can't press
anything it won't let me it won't let me press anything guys
I can't even have fucking moved up break it won't let me
guys I think it does want me to walk back alright actual
punishment guys why didn't you stop me it's time for the
walk of shame I can't believe it I should have bought a gun
I should have bought a gun from the mafia shop
I gotta enjoy like 30 seconds of actually driving the train
and then they put me back on the road they put them they're
making me do the run of shame the run of shame i got the
fuel was like to drive a train for 30 seconds and then i
fucked up and now that it's punishing me it's actually
punishing me i can't believe it it won't let me drive the
train backwards train simulator let me drive train backwards
but now oh my god it's so far it's actually so far the price
of failure all right here you go now back to the train I go
okay there we go I overshot yeah I sort of I went too fast I
was like he he i'm gonna put it to six i'm gonna put the
handle to six and go fast then sometimes sometimes life is
not about going fast chat not in siberia that's for sure why
is she outside i'm in siberia i'm in
thought I thought I learned a lot from train simulator I
thought I was actually doing so well and like you know
actually processing how to how to drive a train but I didn't
realize there was more to trains than just three buttons
there's so many more buttons
there's so many buttons guys
all right we put put that there and then here we go okay
reverse all right get that break out of here there you go
release oh okay okay eight all right we find that we hit it
a little bit right connect this slowly do not see that you
can observe to train an inspection mode what happens if we
hit it does it punish us for it we're gonna find out
we're gonna find out
we'll be fine right i mean it's 500 meter away oh it's
getting faster oh now it's 400 guys whoa it's going so fast
whoa okay this is going way too fast oh no oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh there you go there you go there you go
there you go we should be fine we should be fine okay it's
still going a little bit fast okay there want to see,
though.
See, now it's okay.
Now it's like an okay distance.
We should be able to connect this.
The game won't punish me, right?
No.
It would never.
Why would the game punish me?
See?
Look how slow we're going.
Look at that.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
That's how it ends?
No!
Alright, if you guys want more, you can buy the game.
I think I think I'm done with my train career guys I think I
think I'm done I think I'm gonna retire I don't want to load
it I think I'm gonna retire here We had a good run We had a
My train career is over You can't...
You can't recover from that.
No, what?
I don't...
I'm scared.
I'm scared people are gonna...
I'm scared people are gonna send me to the Gulags.
I don't understand.
How is, like, driving a plane...
Easier than driving a train.
And the...
Like, it's just bad.
backwards and forwards why is there more buttons why why was
there more buttons than than a plane oh my god you know what
best like 15 how much did I spend for that like 30 minutes
of gameplay I put like 30 minutes of this of the train
Siberia how much did I play paid for okay 20 That was a good
$20 to spend it on.
Rusty Corrin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Two hours well spent with the super chat.
WB, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Train Simulator Classic is more of a default experience.
Train Sim World is more of the expand experience similar to
this.
Wait, what's Train Sim World?
Train Sim World.
Can I like What's Train Sim World?
How much is Train Sim World?
Oh my god that's $51.
Wait What's the difference between Train Sim World And like
train Then like train simulator?
Wait what's the difference?
Wait I need to see what the difference is.
There's more?
to the there's more train sims how much more okay train sim
world was it worth it oh my god wait okay guys not over
stream's not over guys guys we're dreams not over don't
leave
over okay 51 that's all right okay let me continue payment
all right don't worry it's a business expense it's a
business expense guys all right how many gigabytes is this
okay 29 gigabytes okay we're fine that's fine that's okay 29
gig the other one was also like 25 25 gigabytes so we're
fine never ends.
It's time for another train.
Guys, don't leave.
We have more trains, guys.
There's more trains.
You thought it was over?
Alright, let me watch this review video.
If it was worth it.
I went off of this Doki's wild ride.
Johnny Lakota, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sin, thank you for the super chat.
Doki train funds.
Oh my god, there's a
Wait!
I should have played this train simulator!
I can go back to my simulator!
Yeah, I'm watching the review after the factory I purchased.
I don't know what's going on!
Guys!
I can go!
There's a- I can go visit the cabin!
Afterwards, mysteriously!
Thank you for the five gifted chips!
They can- guys!
The ride's not over!
Get back!
into the train guys get back into the train guys the ride's
not over we went to Siberia now we're getting back on the
train I'm 10 gigabytes don't worry we have 10 more gigabytes
left get in the train dragoons get in the fucking train
Dragoons, I spent, today, I spent like, like, at least $80
today on just trains, guys.
We are gonna make sure this was worth it.
We are gonna stretch that $80 for this one stream for as
long as I can.
Until I think it was worth the money.
We need to pay off our train debt.
um airborne ninja thank you lucifer chat thank you thank you
i went off of mistoki's wild ride guys i'm on i i have a
debt right now to the to the train mafia so we gotta make
sure we make enough money today to justify all these
purchases guys please let no nobody is getting off the train
until the ride's over all the train sims games today nobody
is leaving this ride until all the train simulator games are
over chat someone please bear all right i'm waiting i am
waiting guys i'm just waiting guys almost there.
It is 27 more gigabytes left.
Zechra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The Doki Express isn't stopping for a while.
Squad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What is that?
That train movie?
Train movie where the world is in the train and if the train
stops, you die.
Snowpiercer!
Yes!
We're just like Snowpiercer!
Guys, and that's a good I'm keeping you all alive Guys,
guys, I'm keeping you all alive in my snowpiercer train
Spawning even super chat thingy.
Thank you.
I'm not leaving.
I'm just getting out to hit the track switch I swear no
nobody is getting out to hit the track switch Only I can hit
the track switch guys because I know what I'm doing I went
through a 30 minute tutorial in Russia on how to on how to
hit the track switch I died.
Spawn, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is the train derail.
Look, I said I'm the better version of the snowpiercer, and
it's not going to derail.
Oh, it finished.
It finished installing.
We gotta thank that one guy who suggested the train sim
world chat.
We have to thank him for introducing me to for introducing.
me to more train games chat i can't believe none of you guys
suggested this why are you trying to hide why are you trying
to hide more train games okay there you go oh oh my god what
is this like thirst trap video of the train Look at this.
Look at this.
Oh my god.
What a thirst trap.
These trains are so high HD.
That's some HD train.
Oh my god.
Look at the...
Oh look at all these buttons I can press.
I wonder if I can call the phone.
That's a slick ass train.
Oh my god.
There is audio, but it's like super quiet.
Railroads are a dangerous place and you should never attempt
to replicate or copy activities you see in game on the real
railroad.
I don't think like us regular people are allowed to like
drop, steal a train.
I don't think we're going to be allowed to be on that train
anyway.
I have to, oh no, I don't want to register it.
No thanks.
Uh, no thank you.
Character select.
I want to be old.
Uh, I have read.
Uh, oh, okay.
See where the advertisement is?
Alright.
Um, recommended get started with training.
Uh, standard experience.
Jump to the main.
You know what?
We don't need the instructions.
We already have the, uh, we already have the, the original
training simulacrum.
later okay let's see uh to the trains we go pick a train
okay maybe maybe pick up quick play okay do something short
yeah that's
okay my god i want to get off my seat in this training
module you'll be learning how wait i wanna i wanna like oh
my god where's the fuck is the sensitivity adjust settings
there we go okay let's see left mouse okay we definitely
need to adjust this sensitivity i think everything else is
fine all right i don't know sound oh yeah sound guy uh all
right here four zero two four electric multiple unit oh my
god why is this why is this the sense so bad okay
controllers all right when do i have two this should be
better for this introduction you will be driving to train i
don't need instructions lock or don't nobody can leave wow
Nobody can leave Also known as the talent is manufactured by
Bombardier and entered service in 2004 Oh, I can make the
desk light lighter Active
light suburban rail car Oh, attention.
That's the attention button BB 4024 is a four-car unit with
a top speed of one They removed the brake.
Why did they remove the brake?
Now set the reverser to forward.
This controls the direction.
Set the headlights to indicate that this train is
operational.
Yeah, the train is operational, guys.
Oh, let's open the window.
I want the fresh air.
I gotta turn this on.
Oh, hey, what's this?
What is that?
Oh, I turned it off.
Okay.
What's this?
There's so many buttons!
We don't need a...
Wait.
Parking...
Parking brake release.
Did I not turn on the lights?
Oh, there it is.
On!
Insert a train brake handle.
Oh, I took the brakes with me.
Why did I take the brake with me?
Release.
Okay, there's motion blur going in here.
I need to get that shit away.
Like, why is there motion blur when I'm driving my train?
What the fuck?
HUD in advanced settings.
Okay, there we go.
Wait, there's no motion blur.
I can feel the motion blur, but I can't turn it.
Max FPS is 62.
No, I need good frames for my driving.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I can't turn on motion.
I can feel the motion blur, too.
I know it's there.
You can't lie to me.
I have gamer eyes.
You can't lie to me, I can feel the motion blur.
Oh, wait, is that the train brake to drive?
Okay.
Open the passenger doors to allow boarding.
Oh.
Unlock all doors.
Guys, you can come on the train now.
Wait, I want to see.
I want to see.
I want to see you guys get in Screw this tutorial It won't
let me see Manufactured by Bombardier Talbot More than 300
Ten serious vehicles Have been produced and have seen use In
more than seven different I don't understand I said skip
tutorial And it won't let me see Left door close okay I need
to close all doors all doors are locked now nobody can leave
nice to release the brakes and apply power push the handle
away from you oh all right let's go hey guys the windows
open let the air in let it on now you've built up some speed
you can return the master controller to the off position to
begin coasting oh okay coasting is a method used to
efficiently maintain speed and reduce motor stress and
maintenance requirements keeping to speed limits is
important if you begin over speeding apply a small amount of
Breaking force by moving the master controller.
You're making me stop at a location?
What if I don't want to stop?
Oh wait, no, that's where you guys have to get off.
Never mind.
You guys have to stop there.
I want to get up.
I want to stand up.
You're now approaching the station.
Begin applying a small amount of breaking force by moving
the master controller.
Almost an emergency break, guys.
Ooh, that was awkward.
It said small, and I'm sorry to...
It said nice job!
You can now use the passenger door controls to open the
doors.
Alright.
Get off the train, guys.
Get off!
Close.
Alright.
Oh, I cannot!
I don't need to be guided anymore!
Guys!
They're not gonna guide me!
I'm not closing my window.
You can't stop me.
My windows are gonna be open.
I wanna get off this...
Oh.
Okay.
Am I driving?
Why am I not driving?
What did I do?
How did I fuck it up already?
Oh, it's because I need to do it 100, right?
Start.
How did I mess it up?
Drive.
Guys, how did I mess this up already?
It's already locked.
Everything is locked.
I made sure.
I made sure everything was locked.
Guys, she left me and now I don't know how I fucked it up.
Guys, she left me and I've somehow fucked it up.
I don't know what I...
did how
did i mess it up oh i did it yeah i did it i don't know what
i did
yeah okay and then i'm level two driver i got achievement
chat oh my god okay wait instrumental light lights off you
guys wait cab train lights wait you guys don't need lights
okay instrument lights sander off where do i have to go
where's my next stop is that one and 500 meters you guys
don't need lights i can't even see you guys it won't let me
leave the train.
It's not fair.
I can literally see the door.
I can see the door.
I know you guys are there.
Alright.
Emergency breaks again.
It's okay.
It works guys.
Yay!
Alright.
And then...
Alright, now you guys can leave.
If you want to.
Why is there glue on the seats?
God, like, thank you for those super shout.
Thank you, thank you.
I did it!
Yay!
I'm so good!
Okay, well What's next, Shroud?
Um, I want to go to...
I don't want train anymore.
I want to actually drive.
Alright.
Dude, a train.
Jump straight in.
Do something more.
I want to be able to walk around.
You did it, Shroud.
I knew you were a train conductor at heart, Shroud.
I fucking knew it.
oh my god i don't what the fuck why is it what are we what
we do what is this train what the fuck guys i cannot see
guys i can't see the train guys how do i turn on the light
this train is too high tech I don't like this train.
It's too high-tech for me.
Guys, I don't like this train.
This train has not too many buttons.
What do you mean?
Help, help, help.
Wait, why is this train digital?
I can't do this train, guys.
This train is too much for this tomato.
This train.
Alright.
To the trains.
Okay.
Pick a train.
Rail journeys.
Got it.
I don't want like...
I don't want people to help me.
Why is quick play like...
Not something I can do myself.
I want to be able to get up and move.
I don't want some lady to tell me how to drive a train.
There's at least six button.
Is this the same thing?
Or can I?
Oh no.
Oh yeah, this is the same thing.
So apparently in quick play it's just like a...
Quick play is just to fool you.
To do tutorial.
Okay.
Alright, to the train.
Train Depot.
I guess we'll do...
jump into a lifelike like okay lifelike all right what do we
want guys what train do we want guys what is a cool train
which one was the one that had so many like buttons i don't
like that train choose a route what train do we get guys
which train is cool
801 all right 8-0-1
That train London's King Cross We'll do that I won't be able
to get up I won't be able to explore the train cabins Which
one runs on call?
Alright, how do I leave?
why is there more but what the what the how do i get up
setting control okay reset automatic i want to get up that's
all i want blow it press e oh e okay oh yes oh my god guys
guys okay okay okay okay okay all right we got open the door
first where's the door down later okay you're not getting
lights oh whoa there we go i'm making sure you guys get okay
here we go we're gonna put it on auto We'll put that on off.
And then we're going to put...
Where the fuck is DSD?
Reading light.
Don't worry, guys.
I got you guys.
I got the reading light on too.
Guys, I got you guys.
Where are the doors?
I got everything.
Oh, door release.
Are you guys CCTV?
The door release?
I'm loading passengers.
Am I loading passengers?
Are you guys getting in?
Oh!
I'm sorry.
Are you guys scared?
Holy fuck.
I got scared of shit out of me.
Who are you?
Wrong game.
What is this fucking platform agent?
I already played platform agent.
yet.
Where's the microwave?
There's people here!
Hello, dragons!
I'm your conductor today!
Guys, hey, I'm your conductor today!
How are you guys doing?
You guys have a great time trying to find the microwave.
I know there's like supposed to be a microwave here.
I'm trying to find it right now.
You guys know what the microwave I saw it on the trailer.
On the trailer, there was a microwave.
I just want to know where it is.
We can't get out the train.
Oh my god, I'm fucking free.
Is there a microwave here?
Over here.
Oh my god, it's the back of the train.
There's the back of the train.
This train doesn't have...
There it is!
This is what I saw, guys.
The microwave!
Wait, I can't even use the microwave!
9 out of 10.
Can't use the microwave, I'm so sad.
Oh, this is like the VIP, the first class lounge.
There's nobody rich enough to be in the first class seat.
Dragoons!
What's going on?
Guys, guys, come on.
Get in my train.
Guys, come on.
Guys, I know you guys have the money to pay for first class.
london i think i don't know that only the rich british live
in london get on the first class pay for my first class
ticket you live in london i know you have money there
london reddit's very expensive oh wait maybe you got wait
wait but you guys would just drive in the car you would not
be on the train my bad my bad i forgot like i forgot that
you would have your own car you would not be on a train
can't afford first class spend it all on turkey bridge thank
you for the super chat cast thank you thank you okay close
we're closing the doors now door closed Okay.
On.
Uh.
Oh, I want to start wiping the windshields.
Okay.
I'll make sure our windshield's being wiped right now.
Windshield wipers be 10.
And then engine start.
Yes, there is a lot of buttons.
Is it wiping my windshield?
Okay, we got that.
Oh, hey, it's starting the way.
Are we... Guys, give me a sec.
It's my first time on this train.
Forward.
Where's the other?
Where's the other one?
Where's the other lever?
Oh, there you go.
Am I going forward?
My...
Am I not going forward?
Why am I...
My windshield's going up.
Guys, we might be a little late.
This is my first time driving this train.
Break?
There's a...
Break, I, you're so, where's the break?
Hello, hello, I don't know where the break is.
Can somebody call me back?
Guys, I don't know where the break is.
Somebody call me back, please.
Please, don't get scared and confused.
Oh,
forward.
Where is it?
Where's the...
Oh, no.
We don't need to open that door.
Is that it?
Local door.
Door release.
Guys.
This ain't funny anymore.
Where's...
Where's forward?
Master Key is on.
I'm going forward.
Ed.
Where is it?
Snow Break?
Is that from Snowpiercer?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Break release.
Is that it?
Guys, who's driven this train before?
Has anyone else drove this?
train before guys does anyone else drove this train before
we need to figure this out
guys this is very important we need oh there's a cup holder
we need to know how to go forward guys Just go outside and
push it.
Press the...
What's the drive button?
There's a horn button.
There's no drive.
I'm blocking windshield.
And then start.
Start.
These are?
Yes.
Yeah.
Check the...
There's no manual!
I chose this trick.
You guys picked this.
trade I thought you knew what you're doing when you all
picked this trade I thought you guys knew what you're doing
you all picked this trade together it's already maxed oh my
god I let you guys pick this trade
start engine start okay i started it all right i started the
engine guys it doesn't look like the engine started guys it
does not guys we're very behind schedule okay someone
announced that we're that we're about to start like pretend
that okay let's pretend that we know what we're doing uh
guys the the red light
start start okay turn the reading light on
your blood that says oh electric I don't know I hope there's
no backlog of cars behind us guys that would be pretty
awkward if there's like a backlog of cars behind us
if there's like a lot of people just waiting on us right now
we're figuring this out close the dude are all closed I made
sure of it what am I oh my door it's fine you don't need to
know I'm making close it now local door closed door door
closed interlocked okay control panel oh maybe it's a fuse
everything is fine there maybe it's back here okay isolated
guys we're behind schedule dokey's the conductor is learning
how to ride this car the other cab there's no way has
anything to do with the other cab guys sorry i'm sorry like
i'm just learning guys look i know you're waiting for the
guys sorry I'm just learning I'm learning okay alright how
do I close this door there we go alright guys I'm sorry your
trains will be delayed a little bit too guys guys I'm sorry
your train will also be delayed a little bit we're gonna
figure this out Do not worry!
We're gonna figure this out!
Guys, I'm worrying a little bit, guys.
I'm worrying a little bit, guys.
Guys, I'm a little worried, guys.
Just a little worried.
There's another door!
Where is the other door?
Oh.
How do I close this door?
closed.
Uh.
Door.
Oh.
Door closed.
Nobody's getting out.
Nobody's getting out of here.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay.
Now!
this engine start and then and then oh oh oh reverse your
off no reverse or forward and boom guys boom oh the
panograph is down panograph up Electric.
Guys, I don't...
Guys.
Because I don't know if we're...
I don't think we're moving, guys.
I don't think we're moving.
Why can't we...
Can't we move our train?
What I want to do is drive this train.
No, we're not, it's not an error.
I need a, we just don't know how to start the car.
That's really it.
We don't, we don't know how to start the car.
We're all stupid.
It's an us issue!
We don't know what to do!
We?
Yes, we!
None of us!
Do you know what to do?
What do you- Alright!
No, no, this is a team effort.
You can't do this to me.
This is a team effort.
You're here.
Jack Goose, you're on my train.
This is literally a team effort.
Why are you on my train if it's not a team effort?
What does it say about you guys, Jack Goose?
You're on this train with us.
Come into the passenger.
Come into the conductor chamber.
We're all going to try and figure this out to get there.
the passages.
This is a group effort.
I have train enthusiasts in my chat.
You go outside and push the train.
We're conducting together.
We are conducting this together.
You're not.
You're going to get fired from your job if we don't figure
this out.
You're gonna be late for your job because you're on this
train.
If you don't figure, if we don't figure this out together,
we just want to...
Exactly!
You want to go to work?
You gotta help me figure out how to start the train.
The simulation world is angry.
It's It's time to learn to be a train enthusiast, guys.
Leo simulated stress.
We're all going to be stressed now!
Alright.
Maybe we acknowledge.
And then we press this.
And then we slip slide.
I don't know.
What the fuck this?
What does this mean?
Push.
I got experience points for that.
What did I press?
Oh, it started beeping at me.
Guys, it started beeping at me.
I'm scared.
The game started beeping at me.
Guys, the game started beeping at me.
I don't know if that's a good or a bad thing.
Where am I?
Chagoon conductors.
Where did they go?
Okay.
Alright.
And then we press forward.
Why is it beeping?
Why are you beeping?
What did I do wrong?
Why you beep?
I don't understand why you beeping Okay Forward Boom Oh no
Press Please Somebody help Somebody help There's a break
release Okay Oh my god.
Oh my god.
How is there a break release?
Somebody help.
Okay.
Press signal.
DSD panel.
Hazard warning.
Please I am the hazard.
We're gonna open this door.
Great button.
Press Okay Go Go Go Please Please go
Please Why don't you move My dragons need to go to work
Please My dragons track was there to go to work
All right control guide there has to be Guys We've been
stuck here for a very long time
Where are the instruction manuals where do i where's my
instruction manuals?
Okay, we're at 10.
We pressed it, but it won't let me.
Guys, this train is too complex.
Fuck, I'm getting a tutorial.
Look at it.
Hey, what?
Fuck this.
I'm learning how to drive.
I'm going to learn how to drive this stupid train.
Explore on foot?
All right.
Which train is this again?
Is it a metro link?
Which one did we play?
Who is this one?
We gotta learn how to drive this stupid train.
Was it this train?
Was this the train?
Was this it?
This was the train.
I should have learned.
I should have learned how to drive this train in the
beginning.
The conductor left the train.
the train to go back to school.
In this training module, you'll be learning how to drive a
vehicle.
Thank you, sir.
How do I drive this train?
You will be taken through the critical driving controls
and... I left the train.
The conductor rage quit the last train and now she's back at
train school.
I did it.
wait i literally just boarded the train oh i mean i could do
that again don't worry i'm gonna i did it take a seat in the
driver all right for this introduction you'll be completing
a full loop of the circuit okay and performing passenger
operations when you reach the next stop prepare the train
for departure
The reverser is used to determine the direction of travel.
Wait, what?
What?
Oh, it wants me a neutral.
Set the headlights as this will let others around you.
Is it this?
Did I not set the headlights?
Is this why?
Was it the headlights this entire time?
Where is there one being said to?
Switch to dim.
Wasn't the headlight this entire time?
You'll need to open the passenger doors.
There's no way.
There's no way they forcefully stopped me.
Door has been released, guys.
I'm gonna trap everybody inside.
Okay.
Come in.
everybody guys come into that train again wait there's
nobody here other people inside my train wait there's nobody
on my train guys guys i'm not like the last guys i'm changed
guys because i know i fucked up last try time on the train
but i'm different now guys it's different guys i swear guys
i know you might have heard about my reputation on that last
train where i left that where we didn't start the train i
left a bunch of dragoons stranded but i'm different now
dragoons i'm different now Alright, close.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank God this is a flight simulator.
Okay, forward.
Okay.
And then what?
How come this went?
What?
It was the lights.
It was the fucking headlights.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking going back.
I'm...
I'm going back to the me
We figured it out we fucking figured it out guys Guys we
figured it out.
It was the headlights.
It was the headlights all this time going back to It was the
Okay, we figured it out We figured it out.
All right guys round two Round two!
Round two!
Get in, guys.
Get in.
Guys, I figured it out.
Yeah!
Come into that train, everybody!
Come into that train!
Doki, the conductor knows how to drive trains for real now.
This time for real.
The conductor actually knows what she's doing this time.
Guys, I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
Oh my god, I knew it.
Oh, it dimmed.
Okay, there we go.
I fucking knew it.
This was the issue all along.
It was the lights.
Okay, close the door.
Close the door.
All right.
All right, we figured it out.
We figured it out.
Forward.
Bam I
love it
Oh my god This calls for a celebration Wind wiping
Woo guys We figured it Guys we figured it out Track On Are
you guys excited?
Oh this is bad Oh this is so bad This is so bad.
Oh,
oh, I stopped.
The tree stopped.
I want to worry.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry, guys.
The tree stopped.
Oh, my God.
I was close.
No, everything will be fine.
Everything will be fine.
It's okay to tree.
The tree stopped, guys.
Thank God.
Don't worry, guys.
Conductor's coming back.
Everything is okay.
Everything is okay, guys.
I'm okay.
I'm alive.
Guys.
Did you guys see that?
I was so...
Everything will be okay, guys.
Everything.
All right.
Okay.
Let's get some air in here, too.
Let's get some air into this.
system all right um uh was that an emergency break oh break
release uh neutral uh min break okay the light is on dead
okay forward go are we going now that's why aren't we going
anymore
Guys, what did I do wrong?
Oh,
it's the doors.
It's the doors.
Okay.
Alright.
Press the pedal.
Guys, why are we going?
No.
Because I celebrated too early and now we're not going
anymore.
Guys, I celebrated.
it too early guys i fucked up all right okay uh forward go
go i don't understand i don't i don't guess i got too
excited i'm sorry i I got too excited.
I mean, I got too happy.
I got too happy.
I'm sorry.
I was so happy, guys.
Because we cannot close this door.
Door closed.
There's one more door.
There's one more.
Oh, it's on the other side.
God.
I'm sorry, Jackoos.
I got so excited.
I got too excited.
Oh, I'll close this door.
All right.
Okay.
door closed there you go there you go wait how do I close
this door how do I how do I close you how do I close you oh
there you go huh guys I'm scared just standing in the open
like this how do I how do I close you Oh, no, I can only
climb.
What do you mean?
Okay, we're close.
Did it close?
Oh, my God.
Where are you?
Guys, how did I close this door?
I don't...
The door is stuck!
All I can do is climb!
Okay, there has to be another closed door.
It has to be.
Closed door.
Did it close?
Oh, no.
Guys, please.
The door is actually stuck.
I'm going to release all the doors and I'm going to close
it.
Do I give up control of the surface?
Yes.
What does it do?
I gave up control.
What did it do?
Oh.
Yay.
We did it, guys.
We're running.
Guys.
We did it.
did it the trains running dragon dragon the train's running
and it's yay we did it dragon we did it dragon no it didn't
fire me they said if i would like to give up so that's
different i just retired voluntarily guys it's different
guys i retired voluntarily chat i didn't get fired i got i
volunteered to retire what the who are you why are you in my
seat i'm gonna press the emergency break get off my seat
that's looking right what are you gonna do about it huh i'm
gonna press all your buttons I stopped your engine.
Wait, how are you still going?
I'm going to take the key.
It's looking right.
We're going to do about it.
Wait, why is the train still going?
It's a ghost train!
They put child lock on here!
Yeah, I'm the co-pilot.
I'm the co-train.
You literally...
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Guys, I'm the co-no, I'm the co-pilot.
Guys, see?
I got my baby chair.
Look, I'm sitting here.
I'm like, I got the, I'm like the baby chair.
Don't piss me off, Dragoons.
I'm gonna turn, I'm gonna turn off the AC.
Guys, don't make me angry.
I'm, oh wait, I'm gonna put on heat during the summer.
That's looking right.
That's right.
Even though I can't control the trade anymore, I can still
control the temperature.
That's right.
You don't deserve a seed, dragoons.
Don't make me turn off your lights too.
Oh, I would turn on the reading light too.
Don't make me do this.
Not the AC.
How could you, you monster?
are we there yet are we there yet did we make it to the stop
yet where you where you meet i'm gonna cook myself oh yeah
i'm gonna turn on the doors too that's fucking right don't
make me don't make me stop the train forcefully dracoon get
over here dracoon i'll pick you up and i'm gonna
You see that door dragon?
That's looking right.
That's fucking right.
Okay, now I don't know how to close this door, so we're
going to leave it open.
We're going to leave this door open because I don't know how
to close it.
Why is it so far?
Did we pass or stop?
I think we passed our stop.
There's no way.
Are we close?
I can't tell.
I know we're definitely behind schedule.
I know.
I think.
Because it says zero yards.
So I feel like.
Are we behind schedule?
Oh, 10 minute ride.
Look at top left.
Oh.
Oh, holy shit, this is a log.
I'm fucking out of here.
Oh,
put me a camera mode.
It's okay.
I can't, I can't, I can't.
It won't.
If I try to jump off, it puts me in camera mode.
What are you serious?
Oh, shit.
there you go goodbye well at least they have a conductee
yeah wait i can like walk all the way there oh goodbye train
i don't think it's gonna stop for me guys
this is my train now
I'm on now I'm on a new train guys Hey new dragons Hey guys
Whoa Wait this train has more people than my other train How
come more of you guys are on this train?
The one I wasn't driving on.
Dragoons.
Why are there more people on this train?
Ha!
Why are there more passengers?
The other train had less passengers.
This is awkward.
Guys.
Wait, are there people?
actually guys there's actually people in first class why do
these drag how come these dragons actually actually pay for
first class compared to my other train oh no she found us
you guys have some explaining to do this is going to London
I can't believe it I can't believe you guys didn't trust me
chat.
I can't believe none of you guys trust me.
I say as I press the emergency brake.
I can't believe it.
Wait, does that mask brake on?
Oh, because I pressed on the emergency brake.
Hee-hee-he-hee-he-hee-he-hee-hee-hee.
Wait, when is this train gonna stop?
I feel like this train has been going on for a while now,
too.
like where are you guys stopping at london's king cross next
station stop who's that is that the one i was at oh that's
the stop i was at earlier we should be close because like i
didn't make that much progress so we should be back there
soon leave me yeah all right guys we're going back to where
we started guys that's fun that's fun i think i uh i think i
like i definitely stretched out the train meta i didn't we
played we played three different train games today it was
definitely it's pretty fun i think it's better letting the
ai drive the train than letting me drive we got three train
games in a row chat is that crazy we actually played three
train games i spent like at least 80 on just train games
today which is like more than like which is usually a lot
more money that i usually spent on like on one stream so
so it's so cheaper than oh you're right it is cheaper than
one singular like IRL train ticket or like IRL train like
those like train collectors.
Are we stopping soon?
Oh my god, okay.
Oh my god.
Are we stopping?
Where is it?
Where's the stop?
Is that London?
Is that London's King Cross?
Why are we slowing down?
Ma'am, why are we slowing down?
That's not the stop.
That doesn't look like the stop.
I hope the other...
I hope the other train is almost there.
I hope the other train is almost at its destination.
Safely pulling in?
What's that?
I don't understand that.
I don't understand that sentence.
What do you mean safely pulling in?
This feels way too slow.
the rules rules what do you mean rules all right let's turn
on the high fan and then we're gonna turn on we're gonna
make sure you guys are at a good temperature oh there it is
there's london cross there it is london kings cross we made
it guys oh my god we made it guys welcome back oh my god
chat we fucking made it wait is this not the destination oh
wait is this not london's king's cross wait why did that guy
not stop
That train didn't stop, guys.
Guys, don't think this is London's king crass.
No, it ain't!
Wait.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I don't think that was London.
Guys, I went to the...
Guys, I went to the wrong area.
It's okay, I just got fat.
Wait, what?
Where do I leave?
how do i how did all of you guys leave oh this is when you
guys want to board to a new area oh i see where are we going
guys i think i don't think i went to london kings cross guys
i don't think now
because a candy how do i get out there it is there it is oh
my god no my soul is tied to the tree
oh no jk jk i got jk i could open the door okay we're fine
we're fine no i'm stuck in the dimension.
No.
I'm stuck in the train dimension.
My soul can't leave.
No.
Oh.
My soul is tied to the trains.
All right.
I'm forever tied to the station.
I'm stuck here forever.
I can't believe it.
I'm stuck you for having i was a ghost all along i think
that was a good time to call it all right i think that was a
good 80 well spent that was
celeris thank you for super chat thank you that laugh is
infectious thank you i'm glad you i hope you guys had fun
with all the train games that we had today chat we played a
lot of train games today uh we streamed a lot longer than i
expected today because i had a lot of fun just playing
random train games with all of you uh but yeah i'm gonna
call it here everybody and rest now um for those who don't
know my youtube figure is out so please check it out and
like support me uh support me and build up your dokey shrine
there a lot apparently a lot of orders have been shipped out
except for the bundles for like the merch store uh we do
have a lot of like the individual items have shipped out so
you might have received an email about it if you didn't if
you order the individual items in the merch store that's not
like the bundles and stuff you should you should receive an
email um if you didn't receive an email yet maybe in a
couple of days you might get the email but yeah Oh my god.
There's so many things going on behind the scenes right now.
I feel like every day is like, every day is like, uh, uh,
like there's so much work behind the scenes.
But, uh, there's so many exciting things coming in the
future.
And it's like, it's crazy.
Thank you guys for all that support, Dragon's.
Uh, almost every day is like a certain work day.
So, but I've been having a lot of fun.
a lot of fun hanging out with you guys too and just like
doing random shit like today we're just we're just playing
random games and stuff yeah guys it's always a great time as
always I'm gonna head out now I'm gonna relax and chill well
not really relax because I have a lot of work behind the
scenes but as always everybody stay hydrated posture check
get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you
stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it I'll see
you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.